a bunch of Republicans criticized Joe
Biden saying that he was acting like
Fidel Castro or something that effect
because of the censorship that the Biden
Administration is admittedly engaging in
a few things one that they're going to
be engaging phone companies to censor
private text messages and the other is
that they are actually themselves
flagging things on Facebook to be
removed by Facebook which is government
censorship well recently news broke
about something called the freedom phone
this is the uncensorable phone and
somehow the media lost or for some
reason I should say they absolutely lost
their minds now it could just be this is
the grift right The Daily Beast comes
out and says this phone is a cheap
Chinese knockoff and it's like do you
know that or are you just speculating
and then all of a sudden these copycat
articles emerge criticizing the phone
with none of these people ever ever
having tested it and no real argument
against it except it's made in China all
right well things should be made in
China I guess we'll criticize things
made in China but does that mean the
phone is bad I don't know I've not used
the phone how weird is it and this is
this is something that always freaks me
out when a narrative emerges that is
definitive when no one's actually done
any legwork on the journalism
no one's not nothing nothing at all
what does the phone do what's what why
does it cost so much why were any of
these questions answered no but sure
enough I can Google it and find like 50
articles claiming avoid it don't buy it
it's bad news and then to see the
weirdest thing people on the right
joining in calling it a scam and I'm
like dude none of you guys have actually
done any analysis on this device isn't
that weird that everyone just
immediately jumps out in total alignment
maybe it's a garbage phone I don't know
how about we get one and we actually
start testing it to see if it actually
does what it's supposed to do so we're
gonna talk about that we're going to
talk about censorship and probably a
bunch of other cultural War stuff but
we're being joined by the freedom phone
guy himself Eric finman hi thank you
yeah well we'll we'll we'll we'll we'll
go over all the stories and everything
like that and do I just briefly
introduce yourself yeah so uh I'm Eric
finman and uh uh I guess my background
before this phone project was in the
Bitcoin World
um the uh the claim to fame um people
annoyingly refer to me as the youngest
Bitcoin millionaire
um and then yeah I mean the media was
all nice to me when it was just that and
then suddenly I did something that was a
very pro-free speech and then without
ever holding the phone in their hands uh
uh you know like they they just wrote
all these hit pieces and all that and it
was a total smear um but yet they all
liked me before this Gizmodo called it a
black box that should be avoided at all
costs and I'm like how did they make
that assessment without actually having
the phone to do any tests on it exactly
and Gizmodo they never reached out
asking for a phone and uh I mean it's
it's it's terrible and these people they
don't they don't know anything and you
see you know Gawker you know who used to
run Gizmodo I mean they they're just
such a such a smear piece and then you
know you see like these Tech
Publications and people think oh well
the tech Publications they must be
credible
um but these these are just you know
total total uh uh anti-free Speech
journalists that just work everywhere
we'll get into this we got Ian chilling
well hello Friday night thanks Tim yeah
man I'm glad you're here we uh been
working on the fediverse you know a
bunch of developers and we're talking
about Mesh networking and the future of
internet and how it might be nodal and
and delocalized so I'm excited to maybe
even integrate that into the freedom
phone in the future yeah absolutely I
mean we have uh uh we have plans to make
this so that way we you know literally
when it comes with the phone that it's
it's capable of being able to do Mesh
networking in the future
um and all that because that's that's so
needed in in the sense of having a
decentralized internet because that's
that's my biggest fear is if they
somehow are able to uh prevent us from
communicating freely anywhere on the
internet I mean we're we're screwed
right on we got Lydia pressing the
buttons I am increasingly uncomfortable
with all the monitoring that's being
done of normal people especially in
light of like the January 6 interviews
and I'm looking at social media
companies and everything so I'm really
excited to have this conversation about
the freedom phone we'll see what it's
all about we'll kind of break it down
stoked before we get started go over to
timcast.com become a member to get
access to exclusive members only
podcasts from the timcast IRL podcast
and you also get an ad free experience
experience we are working through the
bug so you know I appreciate [ __ ]
everybody bearing with us as we work to
make the site better and better and
better in the next week or so we're
going to be launching probably the new
show doing a lot of really great stuff
and it's all thanks to all of you who
did sign up you're allowing us to do
more than we ever imagined so seriously
sincerely and seriously not both the
same time uh thanks for being members
but don't forget to like this video
share this show with your friends we're
going to be a big conversation let's
Friday night you know how it goes I want
to talk about this your freedom phone
let's do this let's talk about this
first uh the story that comes from The
Daily Beast from the uh internationally
renowned technologist technical expert
and expert on the far far far far far
far far far far right will summer oh I'm
kidding he's none of those things maga's
Maga world's Freedom phone actually
budget Chinese phone Maga influencers
are pushing a phone pre-loaded with apps
like parlor and Rumble that appears to
be a vastly more expensive version of a
phone made in China the first thing I'm
going to say to this
well actually the first thing I should
say is will summer is a political
activist like I don't take anything he
says seriously and I don't understand
why there are people on the right people
who oppose censorship who are like well
will summer of all people said it will
Summers published false information in
the past uh uh and yeah I'll just leave
it at that the dude is not an honest
actor so why should I care if he's
making some ridiculous argument in an
article that's clearly an opinion but
not labeled opinion because this dude is
just trying to probably grift now the
thing about The Daily Beast is they
smear anybody and everything that's to
the right of Stalin so for some reason
this article comes out and that's it now
I've even got people in the chat right
now saying it's a cheap Chinese knockoff
have you tested the phone do you know
anything about it I don't so I'm not
going to make that assessment but I
can't say a few things right off the bat
first
they say it's a knockoff of a cheap
Chinese phone well obviously you know
we're sitting here with Eric but I'll
just say this before we get into it and
I'll and I'll ask let me just say
if this is the way I described it on my
on my main Channel first of all I get it
I haven't tested the phone we want to do
a forensic analysis and go through it
but if I if someone was selling a
Chinese canvas and it was five dollars
you could buy it and order it off Amazon
and then if Ian painted me a beautiful
picture of a lighthouse on a canvas I
would not expect to pay the same price
for it if someone takes a a a a a phone
that costs 100 bucks and then puts a
custom operating system on it and
preloaded software and provides the
service and then charges more that's
just called free enterprise it's called
business how is that a negative and it's
made in China what isn't made in China
so these aren't arguments against the
freedom phone there certainly are
questions and concerns but uh we'll
start with this is it a cheap Chinese
knockoff of the Uma Digi A9 Pro
absolutely not we we customize the phone
uh itself so that way you know it's it's
so is that that way it was quality we
looked at their uh looked at looked at
the supply fly chain of the phone of all
the parts that come from it just making
sure everything's secure everything's
safe but no I mean it's not and then two
in addition to just having a custom
phone uh it's uh we did our own custom
operating system on it too is it made in
China uh yeah I mean that's that's the
thing is you can't make phones in the
United States uh which is terrible um I
mean even Motorola they put three
billion dollars into open opening up a
factory back in the day uh for making
smartphones
um but uh you know but didn't you tweet
that it wasn't made in mainland China
yeah yeah it's in Hong Kong it's out of
Hong Kong okay so but unfortunately
that's China no yeah exactly when we
feel like that was our best option and I
have family out in Hong Kong and uh and
everything but yeah I mean you still you
still get that I mean we get our our uh
uh we get stuck parts from uh from
Taiwan as well but then yet they still
call that China and all that so I mean
it's it's it's just China you know it's
a special economic zone exactly it is
it's made by Uma Digi uh we
I think so yeah I mean we we get some of
our stuff from Umi DG and all that stuff
um but uh but yeah we partnered with
them and uh so we basically we have a
Design Lab in the United States uh so
that way we can uh uh uh so we we so
I'll go through in the beginning of the
process so we actually wanted to create
like a blockchain based phone which you
know a little bit marketing there but uh
but my background is crypto and that was
the original thinking so uh me and my
Design Lab which is here in the US we're
like how do we do a phone there's
template designs of a phone that we can
look at where there's other phones we
wanted to look at and see what what can
we take the best of everything
um and then yeah we uh we end up putting
something together and we tried finding
manufacturers
um in the US to do it but it was
literally impossible
um to find manufacturers in the US like
it's just you know because of terrible
political choices made uh you just can't
make a phone in the U.S and you need
like 10 billion to Apple they have
hundreds of billions of dollars and they
don't choose to do it they could
probably figure out that much money well
let's try and get as technical as
possible yeah uh can you who
manufactures the fun in Hong Kong what
company DG and then we get another
Factory as well um because I mean not
not to sound marketing but we did have
high demands now we have another Factory
um as well so that way we're
manufacturing stuff out of there but
they're both Umi Digi uh one of Zumi DG
one's another one oh okay what is that
one uh that one I mean they just have a
long you know Hong Kong name and all
that but uh they're they're just
basically to carry the demand on that
that overflows but yeah we partnered
with uh can you say what company it is
uh no I mean they I I well I could but I
don't uh I don't remember their name or
I do remember their name in my head I
can see it but it's the that's a very
it's a very Asian channel that could be
important I mean what if it's like a
known company that works with the CCP or
something uh they don't and we looked
into that so well and feel I guess don't
take my word for it yeah we can't I mean
Uma Digi is one thing I can be like oh
okay it's a company that makes phones
but now there's like this mystery other
company we don't know what it is yeah I
mean they're we they're just an overflow
Factory that does production and all
that and we we talked with them we
looked at what they do and they have no
connections to the CCP or anything well
that stuff how are people supposed to
trust the phone now if you can't even
say where it's made
um well I mean it's made in Hong Kong uh
and all that but by who I mean umidigi
and then yeah I mean they're just a
people they're just a group of people
that do uh uh you know increase
production the other company yeah and
then we have Representatives only known
and like you can look at the name of the
company and all the stuff and like yeah
hear how people find out I'll put it on
our website right after this no worries
all right yeah on our on our spec sheet
we're going to be adding um you know
sourcing of where we get every single
part from right on and just to clarify
uh Apple and Google also make their
phones in China right yeah I mean I feel
like that's the real stories and in my
opinion I think Apple chooses not to
make their phones the United States
because uh you know unfortunately I
don't have billions of dollars like
Motorola they tried doing it with uh
with uh three billion dollars and they
couldn't do it back in the day
um and uh like I think they're doing
that with the Moto X Etc
um and uh you know Apple they have tens
of billions of dollars
um I think it was uh there was a former
president that asked Apple to actually
make phones in the U.S because they you
know it would be like a 30 billion
dollar Endeavor
um in my opinion and uh and they choose
not to so that's I feel like the real
story of these these companies is they
choose not to make stuff in the U.S and
when you're an upstart and you don't
have tens of billions of dollars to be
able to like set up whole new brand new
factories uh in the United States you
know it's it's you're screwed so one of
the other things they mentioned in The
Daily Beast article is that there's no
specs but you immediately just put the
specs on the web yeah the specs are on
the website and you can look at them and
everything what's the website Freedom
freedomfun.com so feel free to look in
the specs and everything yeah I looked
at the specs I'm kind of just like okay
like their respects yeah I don't I don't
understand I I suppose the argument is
if people didn't know the specs they
didn't know what they were buying but I
find that also kind of weird because I'm
like most people don't know what any of
this stuff means yeah like you know know
a f8 megapixels r13 plus two plus two MP
like most people are gonna be like I
don't know yeah you're gonna look at
that they're on what they're talking
about what is that r13 plus two plus two
Arthur so that's uh r13 so that's like
uh uh front facing camera versus and
rear facing camera so the f is front R
is is rear facing and then plus two
means that there's two cameras plus two
and there's multiple cameras on the back
what do the multiple cameras do what are
they for uh I mean you know just I feel
these days because you need phones that
work with augmented reality that takes
usually multiple cameras
um and then yeah I mean be able to have
like depth in your photos I mean
multiple cameras just all help with that
so I mean zoom in zoom out yeah exactly
so just being able to match
um uh uh the phone you know being able
to match phones of today with something
good in quality I couldn't help but
notice there's no 5G though there's no
5G yeah I mean 5G is just like like real
genuine 5gs just in like a few blocks in
a few cities
um and all that so and we we started on
this phone like a year ago yeah you guys
were explaining to me before the show
that 5G phones are different than the
five gigahertz Network yes yes that has
confused me for years I had no idea
until so here's here's the craziest
thing to me is the amount of smear
pieces that have that have popped up and
that that right away I'm just like
that's a red flag it's like when new
phones come out from Google or for from
whoever else Huawei someone will be like
this phone sucks someone will be like
well you know there's the pros and the
cons I've seen so many tech reviews and
I've seen so many devices to see all of
these companies all these news outlets
every single one line up in lockstep
with the advice not to buy the phone I
was like
now that I find very strange considering
they've never tested the phone and
there's really no issue to be upset with
it if the phone doesn't do what it says
it's a phone whatever I've I used I used
to I I've developed a few apps myself
with my one of my business partners I've
done a ton of work in Mobile hacking
phones and hacking other devices making
programs and I've I've probably owned
like a thousand different smartphones
throughout the production stuff we've
done there's so many different kinds and
and what people got to realize too
when you when you travel and this is
back in the day they use different
frequencies for all the cell antennas so
when I would go to like turkey the
specific frequency I'd have to check to
make sure certain devices worked with
certain phones GSM typically worked in
most places so getting a GSM phone be
okay but like Ukraine was actually CDMA
so I'd have to go and buy a new phone
and they got phones that you can buy
from Samsung in Eastern Europe you can't
buy in the United States and they're
cheap and anyway I'm just like okay so
it's a phone if somebody wants to buy it
because it's got oaiana n on it or
parlor or or Newsmax or whatever what's
the problem now it could be that all of
these news outlets are simply just hey
there here's another let's smear them
because we'll get clicks Their audience
expects to hate Trump they called you
Mago world they're trying to put you in
that in that category simply for you
know the kinds of sites that are or apps
that are put on the phone
so maybe it's just a grift they all
decided it's fair game they can attack
you and you're not going to do anything
about it and you know what hey the
reality is I think most people James
O'Keefe is probably the only person who
actually does Sue for defamation and go
after people and and who Bloomberg
Bloomberg Michael Bloomberg yeah I think
he's super defamation a lot yeah but I'm
talking about the right James Oak keeps
like the only one who does it okay to be
fair Candace Owens we'll talk maybe talk
about that in a bit just had her her
suit dismissed but very few people try
and one of the most annoying things
whenever I've dealt with defamation the
advice I usually get from people on the
right is just to ignore it blah blah
blah because you know and I'm like why
just Sue and make your argument make a
better argument improve your arguments
and find the vector in which you can go
after the people who are lying but
anyway I digress I want to tell
everybody why I think uh the the first
and most important reason I think
Freedom phone
could actually be very very good very
very important and why the establishment
is probably coming after you so hard
first let me say
I have not tested the device
I have not done a forensic analysis on
it I would like to get some of our Tech
experts to crack it open go through it
hardware and software and see if it can
actually do what we think it can do
that's no problem at all there are some
concerns about whether or not there will
be some Chinese spyware perhaps because
you know it's made in China whatever
maybe there's concerns that there's data
leakage in some capacity that it's
spying on you some people are saying
it's a Honeypot that the feds are
funding this to get all of the Patriots
to use the phone and they can track
everything you do and I'm like they do
that through Google and apple yeah
they're called national security letters
if you're worried about your phone being
spied on you are literally in the NSA
database with your existing phone that
can't get any worse they're already
spying on you but here's the thing why
are all these Outlets freaking out
anti-censorship as a service
so when Daily Beast comes out and says
this is a cheap device it's garbage when
Gizmodo says it should be avoided at all
costs I'm like what are they really
freaking out about
most people cannot get an Android device
jailbreak it and and and Flash it with
whatever you know a boot up whatever
operating system they want I'm seeing a
bunch of people on Twitter and they were
like you could just put graphene OS on
it so for those that are not familiar
with this you know maybe I don't want to
get too jargony
phones come with the Android operating
system Android phones do then usually
there's some like scan or bloatware that
a company will put into it so like
Samsung has their specific version you
can actually plug it in hook it up your
computer erase that and put a fresh new
clean operating system and many
activists and hackers have created
anti-censorship and they've created you
know free speech and anti-tracking
and um even like even operating systems
that erase themselves a certain period
of time they've created these things to
enhance individual rights and and and
security
I would say 99.9 of people would never
figure out how to do that I know people
like you you sure you can pull up a
YouTube tutorial like here's how you
make your phone secure and sensor free
all of a sudden you pop up and you're
like just to buy this it's done so what
where is that where is that money so so
they try claiming that it's a cheap
knockoff okay well you've got a custom
operating system on it even if it just
loaded up a sensor free store that'd be
worth it an app store that has apps on
it that Google and apple don't like so
if you want to choose consume you can
the reason I think this is so dangerous
is that it gives the opportunity
assuming it works again like I said I
didn't try it I'm not endorsing it I'm
just saying the concept the average
person who cannot make a device can just
buy one and have it and assuming it does
what you claim it does this is really
really dangerous for the establishment
that wants to track people they don't
want you to shut down we already know we
got the stupid Amazon robot spying on us
we already know that the smartphones
have their microphones on
we know that the NSA is is incidentally
uh collecting all this information I
shouldn't even say incidentally Glenn
Greenwald exposed X key score and the
things that they're doing with bulk data
collection
so if you can buy a device that's not
connected to those Networks you're still
going to get spied on very likely
through just general cell networks where
your phone is what's connected to let me
guys let me tell you guys something I
got an alert on my phone and it said you
know Maryland tracking
how do they know that my phone's in
Maryland how what because listen
of course they know where my phone is
right
but what gives them the right to share
it and act upon it and that's work it's
really weird my phone number is a New
York City number I am not uh uh my
primary residence is not Maryland I am
in Maryland
my phone alerts and says Maryland
information on covet and tracking and
all that stuff and that means that the
cell company has given my data to the
Maryland government or at the very least
the cell company is acting upon my data
at the behest of a government program
yeah I'm not a fan of that I never
consented to them alerting my phone
based on location in that capacity but
you know what Amber Alerts presidential
text messages they know where you are
they're tracking you all the time
if regular people can get access to a
device that adds even one percent or 0.1
percent to their privacy and their free
speech that's going to be a real threat
to the machine which is trying to
eliminate this ideology Classical
liberalism the right whatever
if they are slowly eroding uh Free
Speech Banning people on Twitter Banning
people on Facebook banning people on
YouTube and then all of a sudden someone
can just pay money and get a device that
immediately puts a halt to that
operation
how do what are they going to do send a
bunch of muggers to go steal your phone
they can't do that so you look at what
YouTube Twitter and Facebook are doing
with Banning hate speech promising to do
more to clean up and end the rabbit
holes and then all of a sudden you get a
phone and you can talk to whoever you
want
so like I said we'll have to actually
you know before I actually say it's it's
a good device I'll get you phones and
you can tear it apart rip it apart we've
tested but we're not gonna take the
phones from you oh well get them so what
our plan is no bias then get them right
so once you ship the phones we will
reach out to people and randomly select
phones for testing do it oh yeah perfect
yeah that's perfect not not through you
because look if I went to you you'd be
like oh here's the phone and then we're
back it's perfect it's great oh you're
right you're right attention phones yeah
exactly no randomly get some and all
that happy to put it to the test
but anyway
when we're hearing what With It Bun
Administration is doing with censorship
with the text messages and you know like
yeah I mean seeing an article come out
like right before we launched our phone
about how they're pressuring phone
companies to uh uh uh to like get you
know prevent the spread of
misinformation in your text messages I
mean it's sick I mean that you know if
you're texting your mom or your your
father your daughter your son I mean
it's it's it's terrible like what
they're doing could you imagine if you
were talking on the phone to your mom
and then you said something and it just
cut the phone off yeah like Twitter you
get a label for misinformation right I
mean it's uh maybe you get that in text
message you know maybe you get like a
Amber Alert while you're on the phone or
something your personal phone number
you're talking to your your mother on
the phone and they they blockade you
from being able to communicate yeah
that's insane at least they had the
decency to lie before and say they
weren't monitoring you
um or at least the decency to say it was
for your safety but now it's just so
blatant we've made the argument for a
long time that social media networks
should operate like phones and we would
use that point as an example as to how
shocking it would be should they
actually do that we'd be like you know
Twitter should be like a common carrier
like they shouldn't be censoring what I
say could you imagine if you texted your
mom and your Tweet your text got deleted
I mean that'd be crazy and now we're
here and they're doing it yeah or at
least there's rumors that's happening
but they've stated they are doing it
well from the Press you know from the
White House the Press secretary's Podium
I mean that they're saying they're doing
it I mean it's right or they're PR want
to do it they said that they're they're
working in conjunction with like a DNC
and phone companies to what do they say
uh meet out misinformation but there
have been rumors from people saying that
they've tried sending texts and the
texts don't go through wow on certain
issues yeah but that's something I can't
confirm but I don't know if I have to
considering the White House says this is
what they're doing or at least that's
that's their intention they're actively
working in this direction
and they said that they're actively
flagging things for Facebook in which
case
it's happening isn't it yeah exactly I
mean it's it's that's the thing is the
internet was the biggest uh uh the
biggest weapon in the in the fight
against
um just hoaxes honestly and uh and you
know obviously it spread some you know
you could but I think it's a net good
because you're not able to do hoaxes
like wmds in Iraq anymore and uh and
because of social media because yeah but
they did Russia yeah they did they did
and I I think you would have seen the
number the poll numbers on people
believing that uh way higher if he
didn't have the internet I don't know I
feel like it's it's a in a sense easier
and harder with the internet to do these
large-scale hoaxes right they just make
a fake video there was a video I covered
years ago where
uh some video footage got leaked and I
think it was in Iraq there was a news
report from I think it was like CNN the
BBC
and they were like Bomb Blast goes off
people injured and then someone leaked
footage where you see a car blow up and
then a bunch of people run into frame
lay on the ground and start rising in
pain wow wow so I don't know what that
was you don't know who staged it for all
we know Russia could have made a stage
that claiming it was staged by someone
else you see the point like you never
know who's trying to manipulate false
false flag exactly a false flag false
flag oh snap you're making me nervous
false Flags deep because I go the
Inception I don't know where that video
is from you know you see you see the car
explode you see people run up after the
fact lay down and act as though they
were in the blast we don't know what it
was from but it does call into question
the initial reporting because the
reporting talked about the people who
were there in the blast and then you see
the blast and you're like uh well at
least that story is not true so why is
why is it being pushed out
the I say it's easier and harder it's
easier in a sense that you've got to do
the hard work of making fake content
hiring people to run the sock puppet
accounts but then you have a
substantially uh larger reach in terms
of that kind of manipulation you know
I didn't even know what fiat currency
was until 2007 when I saw Zeitgeist or
eight or whatever I went to school in
the United States grew up in the 90s and
the 80s we've been on fiat currency
since 1970 71 or something I was I never
even heard the phrase fiat currency I
was never taught that never explained
that they can print as much as they want
until the internet and if they found a
way to tax you without you realizing
yeah and if the internet had not come
around and opportunities like Zeitgeist
had not been presented I wouldn't still
not know probably it's crazy crazy yep
and now they're slowly taking those
those rights and those ribs away I mean
look at the internet where it was in the
late 90s you could find wackycrazy stuff
gosh banged up.com
it was just dirt dirty dirty death porn
no no yeah but that's exactly the point
I mean uh the stuff you'd see on lively
now live but now you and take a look at
like torrenting and take a look at like
the height in the 10 years ago Napster
what happened with kim.com you remember
that yeah what did happen what went down
with that he had so so let me break it
down for you the Where the wild west of
the internet was mega upload was a file
locker you would open you decide up
account and then you'd say I want to
store my files here just like Google if
you're on Google Drive you can upload a
video and look it's your kids doing it
you run around the yard or whatever and
then you can share the link with your
friends so they can download it it's an
easy way for people to just all download
something at once and be sending it to
everybody well the problem was people
started immediately using a mega upload
to post movies and TV shows and it was
just almost like I think more than half
of it was piracy a lot of people were
using it but piracy
well kim.com a New Zealand businessman
Who had who has never been to the U.S
had like I guess U.S um I think it was
the the um was it MPAA
Motion Picture Association of America I
could be wrong but like some American
Industries and the FBI I think it was
the FBI and New Zealand authorities raid
his home and arrest him in like the
middle of the night or whatever he's the
super rich guy and they claimed it was
like piracy whatever I interviewed
kim.com for uh Vice and he made a really
really interesting point because I was
like I was trying to challenge him like
why wouldn't you take these things down
why weren't you deleting the movies when
they were uploading piracy and he said
are we supposed to go into our users
accounts and spy on them are we supposed
to start reading through their file
names to see what they uploaded and why
we did take them down he was like when
we would get sent links and say this is
piracy we would delete them immediately
but proactively that would mean someone
would create an account and we'd have to
go into their account
look at what they're uploading and then
even watch the video to make sure
because people can name videos whatever
they want and then he was like it's not
something we could do but we were
actively telling them we will do it it
didn't matter they came in they shut it
all down
the point of the story is 10 years ago
the internet was the Wild West every
movie every show you could watch
anything anywhere and they've done a
really good job doing two things
shutting all that down the piracy and
actually making it a lot easier to watch
movies to be honest I got no problem
paying 10 bucks a month so I can get a
big library of movies I have to worry
about viruses and garbage links and
there have been times where it's like
I'd see a movie and someone sent me a
link and I'd be like oh cool you know an
independence day and I click it and then
it would be some like weird rom-com like
wrongly labeled or something and I'm
like this is dumb I just want to watch
the movie so they created streaming
services it was a great Improvement in
my opinion but the point is what what
happened with the end of the Wild West
how everything became more streamlined
like channels we're seeing it happen now
with social media as well you know I
really don't like the term piracy when
you talk about copying information maybe
illegally on the Internet or whatever
but copying information because a pirate
would steal your thing and then you
wouldn't have it anymore a pirate didn't
come and copy it down and then take a
copy of it and leave you with your
original the pirate piracy is stealing
making a copy of something is different
than that I disagree oh it's it's
completely different than stealing it's
it's I had I had friends who worked in
the movie industry who are losing their
jobs
because they they would spend like you
know a couple hundred grand on doing
like a low budget feature and then it
would immediately get pirated and then
they'd be like guys we turned zero
profit we can't do this anymore sorry I
know people in the trucking industry
they're losing their job modern
Technologies altered the way we
communicate it's it's not piracy that's
the point I I disagree you can't
redefine piracy to make people look like
villains and make it seem like they're
stealing when they're making a copy of
something it's different but I think
they are stealing
You could argue that because of
copyright law but that didn't exist
until like 1600 or something well piracy
happened after that too oh yeah piracy
has been happening for a long time
before I I was never I I was never of
the opinion that people should be
allowed to just copy any bit of
information they they wanted in the
sense that like you don't need to give
someone it's it's I don't even
understand how this is an argument like
if you are if you believe in the in the
rights of the working class to be able
to have someone like let's let's think
about like an invention or designing a
structure someone sits there and tries
to figure out how to make this object
work how to design this engine properly
and then you're like I can copy it you
can't do anything about it and you're
like dude I've worked for 10 years to
design this I'm like we don't care yeah
I'm not stealing it I'm just duplicating
right but if they try and sell it now
they're on the hook for illegal activity
but copying it is and then copying and
everyone gets to use it and and so the
issue the issue there is I certainly
like the idea that if someone invents
something or makes something that can be
easily shared and everyone can that
enjoy the fruits of of that product I
like the idea they can but then to say
that the person who broke their back
worked really really hard to make that
gets nothing for it no that's a problem
if I say you made something uh data and
I copied it and then sold it I think it
should be written into the code that if
I get paid you get paid a large amount
because you're the creator of the
content so what you need to understand
about the content that was being taken
was that the consumption of the content
was happening on mass scales with
millions of people who did not pay for
it
so shouldn't the person who made it
allowed to be compensated for the fruits
of their labor I think artist should be
able to make money you know unless and
if they want it to be available for free
they can you know they can have a
license where it's available to people
you know put it on the open domain I I'm
just a realist I'm an artist I'm an
internet video content creator I'm a
musician if people take my stuff you
can't stop it that's the point trying to
make it illegal and you can no you can't
stop people from Trading information
they they created Spotify they created
Pandora they created YouTube yeah but if
you if you want to go online and look
for a movie and watch it for free you
can it's it's not as easy as it used to
be that's what I'm saying they did a
really good job of shutting down all
these sites they didn't really dirty
ways to be honest like I think based on
my understanding of the kim.com case it
was completely wrong what they did it
was it was nice and they rated the man's
house I mean when they could have just
been like stop doing this but they they
didn't it was like they wanted to put a
show they want to make an example of
people that's the problem when they went
after these people who use Napster like
Metallica went after them suing saying
you're stealing or when there was like
one guy who downloaded MP3 and they
showed up to his house and he got a 50
000 fine or something that's insane that
doesn't solve the problem that's stupid
what solved the problem was just
innovation technology Spotify right and
now you know Bitcoin obviously solves a
lot of these problems too because now we
have the blockchain which means there
can be digital assets that can be can
create can be created and not copied so
now we enter the space of digital
property without fear of being copied of
course then you enter the realm of theft
which is still possible if someone can
steal your encryption keys or whatever
then get access to it anyway to wrap
this back up the internet was a wild
crazy place it was it was nuts what you
could do on the internet and nowadays it
is increasingly becoming more and more
like mainstream establishment television
this show huge thorn in their side but
you know not the most egregious Stephen
Crowder a much bigger Thorn they've
already banned the bigger Thorns like
like uh Alex Jones or Miley Annapolis
he's still on YouTube I don't know what
he's doing but like off of Twitter like
the place where these like
counter-culture individuals have been
able to grow and become prominent they
have removed them because they are
trying to dictate culture they're trying
to control it well the beauty of the
internet when it first came out and you
know I grew you know uh I was very young
I don't remember a time before the
internet didn't I remember when it
didn't exist and uh and and just the
ability that you can be yourself and
that's what I loved about the internet
and and growing up where I grew up it
was you know an amazing wonderful place
it was very beautiful geography I'm from
Idaho
um but you know it's just the ability of
the internet is that you can truly be
yours and that's how it start out you
can truly be yourself and you can truly
be who you really are and it felt like
you know when you're getting into school
back in the early days you know they try
to shun you and I feel like that only
elevates in life when you know you get
stuck in a corporate job you hate and
all that and then and then now they're
coming for the internet and ultimately
if we're all I mean this sounds like a
platitude but it's true is in a sense if
if if we're able to be ourselves you
know that that ends up being a threat to
the establishment
um and then and the problem there is
that the the current ideology that we're
seeing rise is the kind of ideology that
murders people who are inconvenient it
doesn't stop at like oh we're gonna take
your phone away it doesn't stop at oh
we're gonna take your social media away
it stops at you're a threat to the
revolution
you're you're committing crimes of hate
speech off to the gulag I've had people
say to me it was really funny you know I
had one Lefty from occupy to post on my
Facebook wall you don't never forget
you're first against the wall and I'm
like oh yeah a little old me and well
you know it's funny when the splc calls
me a reactionary what they're saying
reactionaries oppose the revolution they
genuinely believe they are in a
revolution to and and it's funny
shouldn't that make them the
insurrectionists if you use language
critical of those who are like the
Constitution is good ah you're a
reactionary
they want to get rid of the Constitution
they want to get rid of this country
doesn't that make them insurrectionists
right well they're the ones who have
more and more institutional power
conservatives are the ones who aren't
doing a whole lot about it and one of
the reasons I think the one of the only
reasons I think we're actually seeing a
culture war is because former liberals
who believe in free speech freedom of
Association you know uh Classical
liberalism have started standing up and
pushing back not because of
conservatives now of course
conservatives absolutely are pushing
back but I think if
If They carried on the establishment
with a unified liberal order of some
sort meaning like you know video young
people who played video games weren't
being uh like told to like engage in a
fringe ideology if they didn't try
forcing the Liberals too far left too
fast there would be no culture War it
would be Politics as Usual we wouldn't
think twice about it but something
happened where the left spread out and
many people who were like center-left
individuals traditional liberals did not
want to agree to this new racist
ideology that was being implemented by
the Democrats and by the progressives
which led them to resist it and led them
to lump in with conservatives and now
you have a large faction of trump voters
75 million people
mm-hmm
you think uh Mesh networking is the
is the answer to this yeah I mean I I
think that I that that's why I think
they dislike my project so much is is if
you have your own Hardware because it
doesn't matter you could have the best
software in the world you know like you
know uh and and if you're leasing
basically on someone else's App Store
and someone else's Hardware you're
screwed so that's why on our phone we
did we put our own app store on there
which has normal apps but also banned
ones and we feature you know Pro free
speech ones but I mean I I think Mesh
networking is the future and that's why
we want to incorporate it on this phone
um so that way you're able to commute
basically what that means being able to
communicate even if they try to shut you
down I mean why I got into Bitcoin in
the first place was uh I guess I was a
weird kid because I was really
interested in currency and before
Bitcoin there was something called
Liberty dollar
um
and they went after that guy I think
they put him in prison or at least said
if you don't shut it down so but what
that was is basically wanting to go back
to the silver and gold standard uh and
he basically set up his own little mini
treasury I think in his garage or
something and you would get you know 10
bill with Ron Paul's face on it and you
could redeem that with him for ten
dollars worth of silver and then you
know small business I have like we
accept liberty dollar sign even it's uh
that's that's in my place
um and and they shut that guy down
because technically it's illegal to
start your own currency in the US and it
became illegal um during the Civil War
uh but you know there actually used to
be I I'd also because again I'm the
Bitcoin guy um and now now I'm the
freedom phone guys what they're calling
me and uh uh but one of the things I did
is I have all these old currencies
because before the Civil War
um it was common to actually issue uh
other alternative currencies whether
that's a company or or an area and so I
have all these things in the Civil War
they want to consolidate all the money
into one currency and then so that's why
Bitcoin was invented in the first place
people go think you know satosh Nakamoto
the founders Anonymous or or you know
what what is the purpose of blockchain
was the anyone who started their own
currency they were either throwing in
jail or threatening them to go to jail
and and that's an or you know and
shutting down any centralized operation
so that's what was beautiful about
Bitcoin is you know you're able to run
it even if they even if they shut you
down you know that's why the Founder's
anonymous because back in the day if you
start your own currency you were you
know I was prison and you were saying
that Mesh networking can bypass issues
with DNS which what were you saying what
are like potential what is DNS and what
are well yeah we got to explain to
people what measurement yeah and explain
mesh number thanks well let's let's
start with Mesh networking how would
that work what does that mean so yeah I
mean uh the goal is is to be able to
have
um uh uh being able to run and piggyback
off other people's devices so rather
than having to rely on uh uh you know
basically again other people's hardware
for for internet
um hopefully you know you can have your
own mesh Network so that way you know
whether that if you have like a box at
home being able to communicate with
other things you know with phones um and
all that being able to being able to
communicate uh so even if they shut down
everything well I'll I'll simplify it
right now your phone here's what people
got to understand about phones your
phone does not send out a a lasso to a
cell tower there is no direct laser beam
from your phone to a tower the tower is
broadcasting information in every
possible Direction your phone is
broadcasting information in every
possible Direction so while the cell
tower
sees your signal and then interprets it
and then transmits a signal which your
phone interprets it's entirely possible
that the signal sent equally into the
opposite direction can be intercepted by
someone as well
this is a large centralized Data Network
Mesh networking would mean my phone
connects to Ian's phone connects to
Eric's phone connects to Lydia's phone
and then all the way down so imagine
this
with a mesh Network you could line up a
person probably I mean what's what's a
cell phones have massive range a few
miles right yeah yeah you could take a
well depending on how you do the mesh
Network and what what bands you're using
you could have zero cell phone towers
you would never have a dead zone ever
again imagine this you're in your office
and you're like my phone just doesn't
work when I'm on like the seventh floor
in the corner because the tower can't
reach here with Mesh networking your
phone would just look for available
phones around it and transmit data
through everyone else's phone network we
wouldn't need cell towers in cities
could we set up like um solid state Mesh
networking nodes that don't require
electricity
uh I mean I think you can have like
cells I think it would all require
electricity
um but you you know you can set up like
solar panels they're run by solar panels
so that way you could have totally
self-sufficient ones where you're not
relying on the grid and I think that's a
huge you know you saw what happened in
Texas being relying on the on the grid
it can it can go bad I'll give people a
simple example that I was on a cruise
ship once and before you got on they
were like download this app it's a
Bluetooth Mesh networking direct
messaging app there's no cell service
your phone will not work remember that
in the middle of the ocean so what
happens is
you get on the boat the boat goes off
you're in international waters and your
cell stops working but somehow you just
got a message from your friend on the
other side of the boat your friend on
the other side of the boat sent a
message to your username hey where are
you at
his phone at the end of the boat saw
Jane Doe 30 feet away jumps to her phone
and then jumped to the next person's
phone to the next person's phone to the
next person phone until it found your
phone and none of them get a
notification none of them get your
message it just piggybacks until it
finally found you there were so many
phones on this boat that it was
instantaneous the mesh Network just
existed as long as people's Bluetooth
runs so the more nodes the faster the
network runs yeah the phones recognize
what the the range of devices so like I
said it's not one to one it's not like
your phone just sends the signal
straight to the Tower and back when that
one phone sends the signal out 15 phones
in front of them all see it and
instantly exponentially just track down
the code they're looking for and then
bling your phone gets a message no cell
tower a match network of a bunch of
different devices I don't know why we're
not doing the technology now in cities
phones should I mean one of the things
they've been doing with like a home
internet is that they also create a
public node off of your own Wi-Fi node
I've never been the biggest fan of that
and I definitely think people should
have a choice to turn it on or off but I
don't understand why we don't do this
although the profit margin of
centralized systems are are keeping it
that way I think intentionally they love
you have to go through Comcast loans you
have to go through their Wi-Fi node to
get to actually I think it might be it's
easier to spy yeah definitely easier to
spy so with a mesh Network though what
if I send a message to you and you were
over there and it went to like 50 people
and then do you would they not be able
to spy on my message to you well that
itself is encrypted so because you know
I mean ideally right if you're using a
mesh Network
um yeah it breaks up onto a little
pieces and all that and then sends it
all United to you they can easily go to
a centralized node
spy but to go to each and every
individual phone with different
modifications and different specs that'd
be a nightmare and you can it's possible
for sure you could use centralized nodes
in the mesh Network it's not like we
have to rip down these cell towers those
could be part of the mesh yeah but you
you'd need backhaul access so the way it
would work is you're standing in the
middle of the desert there's a guy 100
feet in front of you 100 feet in front
of him and then your phone sends a
signal that bounces off of all those
phones and then hits the backhaul cell
phone tower or a hard line connection or
something and then boom it hits the rest
of the internet and you were saying the
DNS could be a problem what is DNS and
how could that how does that affect like
centralized systems or no yeah so for
example when you have like a domain you
have what's called you know your DNS
settings
um so if you're you know that that
enables you to direct people you know
direct direct a certain domain uh uh and
then you know people have been noticing
just a lot of problems
um with you know DNS propagation uh not
just you know you can have sometimes you
know you're not doing it right um you're
like even if you go on like GoDaddy or
any of these things you can look at your
any any place where you have a domain
you have what's called your DNS settings
um and uh uh and then yeah I mean a lot
of people have been noticing these weird
DNS propagation propagation problems
um where it's just kind of going in and
out and I just think that's such a a
vulnerability right now
um where you know they I feel like
powers that be can mess with that
um and and make it so you know domains
can be banned I mean you saw one one up
yeah
gab had their domain seized I think was
it gab
um I think uh their registar ban them
and all that but that's the next step is
you can go to uh one of the best domain
registrars is called epic Epi ik
um and uh that's where we host our
domain and uh and that's where I believe
gab hosts their domain as well don't
they do their own everything now though
aren't they building their own
everything yeah I mean I think Gap yeah
I mean they have to I mean it's honestly
props to them in many ways I'm and one
of the you know we made uh gab doesn't
have an app so on our phone where we
have gab right in our app store
um because when we built basically a
whole app around their website so that
way when people get it they want to
install it they can get it didn't they
use fetiverse though these gab switched
to the fetiverse oh did they oh I didn't
know a while ago Wow Wow for those for
those that aren't familiar the fediverse
is like Twitter but decentralized yeah
so that means if uh it was really funny
the Mastodon I think was the biggest
node the biggest website that used the
the fetiverse and when gab switched over
all of a sudden all of these evil far
right people were now in the same
network as the far left on Mastodon and
they pan and they're like we're Banning
these servers so we won't see them it's
really really funny actually the hackers
who are like we're creating a free
speech Network the goal of like the
federal verse was to create an
uncensorable Network decentralized
Internet to stop like the feds and the
establishment but then when the hacker
Community got woke they immediately were
like Yay establishment and then turned
over like their servers to being banned
to blocking and everything but anyway
yeah it's weird how the hacker Community
went whoa to me that's surprising I know
right yeah it's like out of a lot of
people I mean Pro FBI yeah fed wow
defcon's probably gonna be fun this year
a free speech doesn't mean uncensored is
what I've found like yeah if you allow
everything to happen then people there
will be mass chaos and people won't be
able to speak properly because they'll
get beat down when they try to talk and
it's just hey everyone's able to do
everything so you have to create like
you have to censor evil in a way or
whatever destruction you have to censor
that so that people can speak freely you
know that's as per the US Constitution
we've set up rules so that we allow for
free speech well it's similar with the
internet but it's dangerous because if
people decide who's the Arbiter you know
then they can be pretty heavy-handed the
difference is speed so when it comes to
the real world first of all people have
their faces on their face you know and
on the on the internet you have
anonymity which is good it could be good
in a lot of ways it can be bad in some
ways ultimately I think anonymity serves
a better more good than bad but imagine
if every human being on the planet had
the superpowers of the flesh every
single one somebody would be holding a
feminist rally at a you know a local
community center and then some
anti-feminist instantly could be there
shouting them down same thing would be
true of antifa so you get some
right-wing people saying We Love America
and then instantly 10 000 anti-america
flag burning antifa are all screaming
and no one can talk
so in the real world we have physical
security
that's not censorship if we have a
private event so the challenge I suppose
is
the modern left says Twitter is a
private company they can ban whoever
they want and it's like yes but they're
like the only one they've monopolized
the space and that's creating a strain
on discourse and it's causing serious
problems in this country but you know
what the problem is these leftists enjoy
the fact well first of all
some of them enjoy the fact they're
winning because they have the control of
the institutions but most of them are
just like I'll say whatever I'm told to
say because they just want to ride the
wave what they don't realize
is that they're destroying the fabric of
society and here's the way I put it a
lot of people think you know super
villains want to destroy the world right
I was watching Austin Powers recently
and Dr Evil and which which one is it
Gold Member he's he's like no no this is
in the second one he's like even after
they pay me all the money I'm still
going to destroy the cities with liquid
hot magma it's like no you wouldn't
because that where do you spend the
money after you destroy all the cities
but again it's a comedy it's funny those
people don't realize is that they're
like Yay I'm winning and it's like
congratulations your parent Victory will
make you the king of a pile of rubble so
you may want to have you want to have
political battles but if you are
creating such a strain that you are
causing serious physical conflict and
violence to where Joe Biden just went
out and was like do the Republicans
think the Democrats are sucking the
blood out of kids like what the
president just said what like come on
you know Donald Trump said Kung flew but
geez Joe Biden that was way that's how
insane they're being driven by the fact
that they are high on their own Supply
let me uh let me let me just say it I
say I'll say it so so so so good Jack
Dorsey he invents Twitter and then he
just takes the whole vet and sticks it
in his veins and believes all the
psychotic garbage that the toilet has
produced and is being flushed into his
veins they are high on their own Supply
and eventually people are going to freak
out from The psychosis of social media
algorithmic chaos and and it's always
gonna go
well they're going to build Minds is
what they're going to do and they did it
they built it in 2011 I was there uh
yeah the centralized internet is very
very dangerous and having a CEO decide
what gets to be said on the network is
also very dangerous because the CEO can
change and can become a psychopath yeah
I mean dick Costello was like that he
went you know former CEO Twitter I mean
he went from saying we're the Free
Speech wing of the Free Speech party to
just you know ranting on Twitter about
how they should be stronger on the bands
they're high on their own Supply yeah
it's a downward spiral they start they
start seeing they get into they get into
these arguments you know a cgp gray has
a great video called this video will
make you angry where he talks about how
people rile each other up about the
other and he said that they don't
actually talk to each other like you
know if it'll be like you know I'm I'm
pro-tim and Ian's Pro Ian but instead of
us actually arguing with each other
about our beliefs we I argue to you and
he argues to Lydia I get so annoyed when
people do that that's what they do and
so what happens is our our mental image
of the other gets crazier and crazier
and crazier until ultimately we're just
like you're evil the problem is
the people who control the institutions
got high on the supply of leftism they
were being fed algorithmic junk that
would generate more clicks and more
traffic for these ragebait blogs and so
they started to go insane believing
insane things let me let me tell you
guys something
I I've long ex I've often explained how
The algorithmic psychosis took hold in
America for those that aren't familiar
I'm gonna explain it for those that are
familiar please bear with me as I
explained to those who are not familiar
in the late 2000s Facebook and YouTube
and Twitter and whatever else we're
trying to figure out algorithms not so
much Twitter Twitter didn't go
algorithmic for a while they're trying
to figure out how to get the most amount
of engagement on posts so they created
algorithms
regular people Ben would see a post and
it would say I like chocolate chip
cookies and they would interact with it
and then Facebook would be like people
seem to like chocolate chip cookies show
them more posts about cookies but then
one day someone posts a video of a black
man being beaten by police and all of a
sudden a million shares 300 million
views and the Facebook algorithm without
any disdain For What the video was said
this is what people want to see no I
don't think people wanted to see that I
think they were mad about it I want
people to know because they wanted
Justice well the algorithm then started
feeding more of these videos but more
importantly humans figured it out humans
figured out I get way more views when I
post these videos so the rage bait blog
started posting more and more and more
of this in fact at one point there was a
website dedicated to nothing but police
brutality that was in the top Global 500
websites all they did was post police
brutality videos then something more
magical happened the discovery of
intersectional feminism wait a minute if
we combine racism and sexism we don't
just get X views or why views and we
don't get X Plus y we get X Y views an
exponential increase by combining the
keywords thus we saw the rise of
intersectionality which was was this
idea which is written it stems from
critical race theory that a black woman
experiences a unique kind of sexism and
racism that a black man and a white
woman would not experience creating an
all on all new interpretation of racism
what ends up happening is you have all
of these companies producing rage bait
to the to the great to Grady every
article is police brutality non-stop
mike.com started as my understanding is
a Ron Paul libertarian website no way
did Mike start off as Ron Pauly that's
that's why there was an investigation I
read about and saw correct me if I'm
wrong everybody but it started off by
just being like what was the internet
what was big on the internet back then
Ron Paul Ron Paul reviews number one on
Reddit I mean that's why I first heard
about Bitcoin was a Ron Paul event but
then something happened they realized
that anger was was the number one with
the emotion that caused the highest
amount of shares
so that instead of being about Ron Paul
it became about police brutality now you
got to understand too the Ron Paul crowd
overlapped with the police brutality
crowd because Libertarians didn't like
seeing people be beaten by cops and they
liked Ron Paul too but the police
brutality people found that enraging
people with intersectionality was worth
more and eventually it leaves the Ron
Paul people behind who are probably to
be completely honest more rational in
their thinking and they were looking for
information they were finding it they
were getting away from the mainstream
which brings me to the current state of
our generational algorithmic psychosis
someone who is 10 years old in 2008
goes on Facebook maybe for the first
time I know they're not supposed to
because you're supposed to be 13 but
they're 10. and what do they see nothing
but police brutality videos every video
in their feed is a cop beating a black
man five years goes by a third of their
life is inundated with non-stop posts of
police beating black men now does that
mean that more and more cops are doing
this no not at all it's just that when
you have how many how many million 300
something million interactions with cops
per year a handful of them are going to
get really really bad some may be taken
out of context
now
it's it's 10 years later we're talking
2018 and these kids are now 20 years old
half of their lives they have seen
nothing but the police but brutality
videos and racism and sexism
now it's 2021.
now they're all in their in their early
to mid-20s these young people most of
their lives inundated with algorithmic
psychosis yeah is it true that police
sometimes will beat a person unjustly it
is does it does sometimes mean a lot it
actually doesn't is a lot relative okay
sure it is but out of hundreds of
millions of interactions with police a
tiny tiny fraction I think the Wall
Street journals had 19 unarmed black men
were killed by police
that's a problem each and every one of
those deaths is bad but when you play
those videos on Loop for a decade
people's world view these kids they grew
up in a world where the only thing they
ever saw were these videos played on
repeat sometimes from different angles I
mean the internet is like raising kids
now I like I feel like I was raised by
the internet and I mean I had a great
family and all that but a lot of people
they don't even have a great family and
they're raised by the internet but these
kids grow up in a world that doesn't
exist yeah so I remember uh I noticed
this from time to time you go on Reddit
and I'll see the same police brutality
video from like 2014 and it pops up once
a week because it gets Karma because if
someone says I want to get internet
points they put it they post it and they
know people are gonna upvote it and they
don't know or they don't care that it's
really old that 10 year old kid sees
that video every week and then they
forget and they see it a month later and
then they engage and these these videos
are constantly recycled in this way it's
it's it's algorithmic psychosis that is
warping the mind signs of people who
live in the internet who are growing up
with it the other thing that is causing
the the chaos is what I call the scaling
problem
and it's basically if you have a hundred
police officers and one of them is a
dick who uh and a psychopath who beats
somebody that's one percent most people
are going to be like arrest that guy
problem solved it's just one guy
if you have a hundred million police
officers you've now got a million cops
going around doing all the stuff that's
a very very serious problem but it's the
same percentage now it's not nearly that
high in terms of bad police officers we
do have problems with cops don't get me
wrong in terms of like enforcing unjust
laws or seizing people's guns and things
like that in violation the Constitution
and violating people's Free Speech I've
seen it the cops who sprayed those girls
uh the women at Occupy Wall Street for
no reason just walked up Tony Baloney
and he sprayed her that's wrong but when
you look at the actual ratio
these people who grow up in the paranoid
delusional world of of Rage bait
algorithms and their whole lives have
been inundated with this they live in
this world that's completely inverted
the point zero zero one percent of cops
who are actually doing these things
become the 99.99 of cops because they've
never seen other interactions now
they're going into politics now they're
voting so if you think everything is
going to stop what people need to
understand is it's not about you it's
about the kids from 10 years ago and
where they are now it's about the kids
who are 15 years old right now what
they've been raised on and who they will
vote for in the next three years which
could be crazy crackpot far left cult
member who microwaves their underwear
and is using a curling iron to make
pancakes because that's what they see on
the internet could be Kanye West I
believe that's not so bad I believe I
love Kanye so much I mean those Sunday
services are amazing I mean that's why I
want to get into politics actually I
feel like Kanye was one of the biggest
motivators
um because just just seeing someone you
know like in the song reborn and all
that with Kid Cudi it was it was just so
beautiful you know I want all the smoke
I want all the pain I want all the blame
what an awesome thing engulfed in shame
and uh and that's that's what made me
want to because I've been like what got
me into Bitcoin was was Ron Paul and all
that and that whole world and meaning
some guy had a had a Bitcoin it was
actually Adam kokash it was actually an
Adam kokash event Paul people I forgot
the I mean it was around when Bitcoin
had come out recently and my older
brother brought me to an Adam kokash
event and he uh he uh got arrested the
Jefferson Memorial for dancing and all
that do you remember that I vaguely
remember that yeah and then my brother
uh we flew in and uh we went to go
protest that
um and then yeah so it was like a
footloose like protest and then some guy
had this orange uh Bitcoin shirt on or
is that an orange B and it looked like a
dollar sign like what's that and he's
like it's Bitcoin man it's gonna end
Wall Street bro you know ran off you
know what I love about it started at all
you know what I love about Bitcoin what
the people who endorse it early on had
no idea what it was at all and the
reason I didn't buy is because me and my
friends
more so knew what it was now uh so my
story is that back in 2011 Bitcoin was
at 70 cents and I look over to my friend
I'm an Elliot hackerspace 70 cents per
Bitcoin and I'm like I was like Hey I
was like I got five grand in savings
should I just buy all this bit like put
it all in Bitcoin because I'm not going
to touch the money you know what I mean
it's gonna it's just my savings hitting
my bank account and he goes dude
like first of all how do you even buy
this stuff and then second of all it's
probably a scam like somebody makes this
and they tell you it's valuable and sure
it's like you know winner Bitcoin but
he's like what can you really do you're
gonna buy it and then a month it's going
to be a fad and then you're going to
lose everything and I was like that's
that that's a good point I won't buy
well I'm familiar with the people
calling product scams when they're not
so I remember seeing it thinking like
okay so now my currency is going to be I
gotta write a string of numbers on on
letters on paper if my paper gets lost
or burned it's gone forever and if I
lose access to electricity I can't I
don't have my money so I didn't get into
it but what was your impetus to get into
it well so actually yeah do you want to
tell us what year and how you yeah I got
into it 2011
um as well so I had about uh my
grandmother who was very old and uh and
she gave gave me a thousand dollars and
she's like you know Eric use this for
your scholarship you know one day go to
school and uh I'm gonna buy fake
Internet money and that's what I did
so that's what I ended up doing
um so I bought that at my yeah my my
brother taught me how to like get that
out and actually buying Bitcoin was
easier back in the day because it was
like you could just pay some guy over
PayPal you know and then uh and get
Bitcoin sent to your wall just I mean
you had Bitcoin faucets back in the day
which is where they would give away free
Bitcoin I got 0.15 Bitcoin from that
faucet wow yeah bitcoin.org right yeah
that computer got destroyed though oh my
God so I I I I probably I don't even
know how many Bitcoin around that
computer the computer I had back at the
hacker space because I didn't I didn't
put my savings into it but I still did
get some Bitcoin it was worthless I I
was like whatever it's like I had like a
dollar yeah that happened to my friend
he he American Airlines lost his bag and
that had about 500 Bitcoin on it no yeah
I know I know where did you store it in
the beginning uh back in the day and not
definitely not now but I just stored on
my laptop like you download like The
bitcoin.org you know yeah desktop wallet
and that's what you did I'll pack a
socks if anybody remembers that and yeah
I mean I was a weird kid I mean some
kids had video games some kid at sports
mine was Bitcoin I just spent every day
and I ended up actually I dropped out of
high school because I had some Bitcoin
money then moved moved my butt to uh to
Palo Alto Silicon Valley and just like
you know tried to do a business and all
that and that ended up going well but um
eventually sold that company put it all
back into Bitcoin but Bitcoin to me I
mean when I first got into it I actually
did think it was going to be big but it
was kind of in the way like you hoped
for World Peace like it's like why don't
you hope for it but you don't know
there's a funny meme where it's like
some some there's like a guy who's like
wearing a nice Polo and glasses and he's
like Bitcoin seems interesting but I'm
not entirely sure that people will build
confidence in this decentralized network
but I'll look into it and the next guy
is like fat with like a beard and flies
and he's like I want to buy drugs on the
internet and it's like that guy's a
millionaire now yeah because he was just
like some scumbag it was like I don't
care did you uh pre-install uh wallets
or on the freedom phone wallets um
there's a crypto wall on the phone
what's it called uh it's uh it's called
metal pay actually so that's can you do
you have the phone yes
do you want to pull out your phone so we
won't use the pronouns I know I know but
that's another thing like everyone told
me when I got into Bitcoin you know and
they all they were all like yeah bro
that's a scam bro get out of here
someone took your money on the internet
some guy named Bitcoin took your money
in there you know and that's how it
happened and then I I got into an
argument with some and cap guy
it was funny because I was like talking
about this is this is like probably 2012
or 13. I was like so Bitcoin was still
relatively cheap back then and I was
talking about my concerns
and he didn't know anything
at all and he's probably like worth
hundreds of millions of dollars right
now and I'm like I wish I was dumb you
know what I mean and just like oh cool
Bitcoin and cap woo Anarchy and now I
just bought a bunch not thinking about
it but I was like hmm there are some
very interesting problems with this we
saw some of the hard Forks uh uh or not
the hard farts the hard Forks the the
Bitcoin cash there was the ACT no no The
Accidental ones oh really do you
remember when uh I think it was in 2013
Bitcoin forked on accident
oh yeah and then they had to like do an
emergency like no no that's not the real
thing anymore and like switch to this
node and so I was like but you know the
mistake I made back then was it was it
was an investing in
the one thing the end caps understood
was that it was a decentralized
non-copyable asset that was difficult to
locate and that's all that really
mattered and so I was in cat back when I
was you know 12. but there's that
there's two things there's that and that
in and of itself was like we don't care
what the value of the Bitcoin is I can
have this Bitcoin and trade it and it's
easy the other thing was back in the day
it was actually a very uh interesting
way to transfer funds very quickly
internationally not because you cared
about the value of Bitcoin put it this
way
I need to give you let's say I need to
give you a dollar and I like you're
you're a thousand miles away
so I can't hand you the dollar so what I
do is I go on I send you a dollars worth
of bitcoin and then you immediately sell
it for a dollar so I just transfer the
dollar instantly no neither neither of
us are holding Bitcoin I go to the site
I say buy Bitcoin send and then you go
accept Bitcoin sell the dollar
transferred like that that was an early
on that was very very early in bitcoin's
history when I was like now I started to
understand why this is such a powerful
tool because it basically cuts out a lot
of the financial infrastructure for
transferring funds very quickly it
didn't matter what the price of a
Bitcoin was because if someone could
transfer value instantly then there
would be more demand for buying than
selling and so
that's when I was like okay I'll get
some Bitcoin I started taking more
seriously and since then I have I mean
that yeah I mean the end caps back in
the day I mean I was really into that
and I still still a part of me
um and uh uh but I mean that was that
whole world was just you know a bunch of
I mean that's that's how all great
things get started is people that are
are a little different and all that and
then so but how did you uh you so you
bought in 2011 you bought all these
Bitcoin and then when did you become a
millionaire uh yeah so uh I became a
millionaire at 18 so I was like 12 back
then so again that was but you bought
Bitcoin when you were 12. yeah I bought
Bitcoin I was 12. and again it was
easier back in the day because uh you
know uh although I ended up having to do
it later but all the kyc stuff you know
you could just like yeah PayPal some guy
on local Bitcoins and uh so that's what
I did and um yeah I mean I was 12 years
old and I just spent every day I was
like mowing lawns just to try to get
more money to put into it really yeah
see that's that's it because a lot of
people say
like when I tell that story about having
the five grand in savings and wanting to
buy Bitcoin everyone responds with you
would have sold it 20 bucks and I'm like
you're correct if I put 500 Bitcoin and
hit twenty dollars I'd be like I'd sell
right away I'd be like just get up
because I didn't I I wasn't smart enough
I guess I didn't have the vision I
didn't see it I think to me it was just
my whole identity was wrapped up in
Bitcoin because it's like what are you
gonna do as a 14 year old you know with
with this money when it went up and then
that and then again it was just like I I
was just obsessed with Bitcoin and it
was my identity and it just inspired me
of uh to do so many other things um but
yeah I came millionaire at uh 18 uh I'm
22 now I'm an old man
um I did that and then yeah a bunch of
Articles came out you know youngest
Bitcoin millionaire um which was nice
but you know ultimately was you know
cool I guess but you didn't buy Doge I
did buy some does early on
um I did Cash Out Doge early though that
was that was my stay I now have some
coin in in uh in Doge
um and all that but uh uh but yeah I
mean I was I was all in Bitcoin I mean I
remember I mean had like 300 bucks on
Dogecoin like back in the day and I was
like well this is as far as it's going
to go because Dogecoin is one of those
coins that has lasted for such a long
time I mean they did the whole NASCAR
thing early on and then after that faded
I was like wow maybe Dojo I love how in
the early days of Bitcoin there was like
thousands of alt coins we'll call them
altcoins and they were just like clones
of Bitcoin with different names yeah and
then people would be like this is the
one that's going to beat Bitcoin and I'm
like it's nothing it's all the same
thing it's like you just cloned the code
and then made it and then sold it and
people made money doing it it was it was
crazy because even if it was almost
worthless you could make like a million
coins go on some some uh trading website
and people would be like I'll give you
Bitcoin for it it was so scammy I know
and it still is yeah yeah I mean
Litecoin was one of those things I mean
seeing Litecoin like ethereum's kind of
the new Litecoin but I remember Litecoin
was just you would always it would
whenever Bitcoin went up like Litecoin
was always at number two and they would
say Bitcoin is gold Litecoin is silver
yeah exactly exactly I mean it was
really really the logos and it was it
was uh that was just such a crazy
beautiful time and uh wild wild west of
the internet it was the Wild Wild West
on the internet and uh and then again I
mean I remember there was this thing
called world of text and it was like
when Chrome first came out and you had
like a webgl I think it was called and
it was uh and and basically it was this
whole just giant text Page where you
could just write anything and be
yourself and all that and that was what
was beautiful and and you know and again
I just feel like uh not not to tie it
into the today but I mean just it's just
they're taking away the ability to be
yourself and people use the terms like
free speech and and all that and I mean
that's that's a the perfect term for it
but what does that really mean it's the
right to have your own voice the right
to be yourself can I see that phone yeah
absolutely so here I'll uh open it to
the camera so this is the Box yeah
should I be fancy with it yeah that'd be
fancy yeah so
this is the freedom phone guys and all
that it's beautiful it's a beautiful box
okay cool cool yeah my microphone here
so here we go I'll uh you're probably
your your frame is probably like at your
chest okay okay so there we go so this
is it and all that's a little bit up a
little bit there you go it still darkens
the camera because of the white yeah
yeah absolutely so here we go um here
I'll hand it to you in just seconds and
all that but yeah this is what it looks
like you know it's a quality phone
um and all that and then oh yeah it's a
quality phone and all that and you can
boot it up you know we did uh we we
basically combined some of the best
um custom roms uh on Android plus I
hired a really great CTO
um to basically re rebuild
um you know and rebuild Android from the
ground up so that way you can uh so it
was Secure and all that's when we mix
lineage OS graphino s
um we took some of the best parts of all
these things and then you know it was
tricky to do because that can that could
break a lot of things
um and we did that and uh and then yeah
so you have like Trust on there which is
uh uh a privacy guard for your phone and
then you put it up
um and then we have uh here I'm just
trying to say one of the things we did
is we made this really explicitly kind
of uh political in a way because we
thought about making like should we make
this phone like a little bit more
um like a little bit more neutral um in
a way um and not so like hard standing
on uh on on kind of free speech and and
you know right-wing politics
um and all that but we wanted to you
know I feel like we did a good job we
wanted to have like I'm never afraid I
guess of being provocative and I think a
lot of people they don't they're they're
I can hand this to you by the way if you
want to play with it yeah um Freedom
phone yeah Freedom phone how long did it
take for how to Duck Duck Go on it yeah
so duckduck goes right on the home
screen Brave browsers and default
browser yeah we preload fortnite because
we did that as a troll because uh apple
apple banned fortnite
um off their App Store so again they're
they're not just uh they're not just
Banning conservative apps they're
banning apps like fortnite if they don't
pay up or if like some governments like
for example not that I use this app but
but Grinder I mean that's you know like
Tinder for gay people I mean that's they
banned that they banned that not in the
US but a country asked them to be I
forgot which one but it was like so the
so they're responding to countries and
all that and that's the problem with
these huge huge multinational
corporations is you know they they're
just in it for the money and all that
and that's the whole purpose of of of
this phone and all that was uh was was
to make a phone that was a true
alternative to the to Apple and Google
do Apple and Google multiple SIM slots
yeah you got multiple SIM slots and
everything
um and all that so how long did it take
from the drawing board to prototype and
then from the prototype to finished
product you can connect it connect it to
Wi-Fi too if you want to use the
internet so that's like a testament so
where's the camera use the camera so
it's at the bottom right corner oh I see
yeah yeah exactly
oh looks like a camera yeah it zooms
look at that hi
so I think uh uh I'm looking at the
specs and I think the umidigi A9 Pro
actually has a better camera uh yeah so
we we customized the camera on
everything like the problem is is we
want to make sure that on the supply
chain front that we got our parts in a
secure way
um and all that so that way uh like we
we just didn't feel satisfied with the
Umi DG
um their camera oh yeah thanks
absolutely oh I see well I I Googled it
they say they have a 32 megapit a 32
megapixel megapit megapixel uh a camera
actually has a uh less uh uh they have
an octa-core processor which I think
yours is also also we have an octa-core
processor but yours is eight gigabytes
right
epic that one human can build go and do
something like this well thank you I
mean obviously you have a team of 20
people and factories and research and
factors how long did it take you guys
from start to finish it took a year it
took a year so again this started out as
a uh as kind of my background is crypto
and all that we thought well would it be
great to have a phone you know
pre-loaded with a bunch of you know kind
of blockchain based apps and everything
um and uh uh and we thought about that
but one of the reasons we wanted to call
it a freedom phone was to have that
provocativeness and to go right into the
like I I think that there's a huge
problem of people a lot of people you
know if they voted for Trump they don't
want they're scared to Market to uh uh
and you know I voted for Trump and and
everything they're scared to Market to
these uh uh scared to Market to this to
this audience you know you see look at
there's like a pillow company right
that's the least political thing ever
but if they they say they care about
your values and they do
um you know they they end up they end up
doing well but getting did I know so
many friends they have some of the best
online alternative education apps in the
world that would appeal in my opinion to
a lot of right-wing people that that
care about alternative education because
right now the the education system
itself in my opinion it just teaches you
know uh CRT and a lot of left-wing
values and you know you could say you
can have that argument but in my opinion
there's no ideological diversity so
that's another reason why I think I'm
getting attacked so much is this I'm
unapologetically Free Speech you know
I'm in my opinion you know I'm a
republican so and I think that's the and
it's weird because it flipped it used to
be that Republicans back in the day in
the George Bush era they were kind of a
little bit you know not so good on free
speech and it used to be the left and
it's totally flipped now I'm like a
one-issue voter I just care about Free
Speech yeah I think centralized
education is a big problem it is good to
build social cohesion through what we
understand and know but I think the
modern day education is teaching people
how to learn not what to know exactly
and this education system seems to be
shoving specific information into
people's heads as opposed to teaching
them how to think critically which
exactly I mean I dropped out of high
school because I love to learn not and
and that was and that was the problem is
is that you know you look at Richard
Branson he dropped out same age as me um
and all that is I I love to learn and
that's why I had to leave because they I
felt like if and that's one of the
reasons why I care about Free Speech
because I was like you know I've done a
TED Talk
um I had met you know with with Jimmy
Carter and and all that like Time
Magazine the media had liked me up until
July 14th when we launched this phone
and all that and uh like I I had all
these like literally I did an interview
with um Business Insider
um and all that before they didn't know
that I was launching the phone and it
was very nice
um CNN had me on to talk about crypto a
few days and they didn't know and they
wrote These glowing things
um but uh about me so I I pulled up I
had the wrong specs before I had the A9
Pro on the A9 the specs look the same
yeah
what's the difference between the pro
and the I guess the pro is a better
camera it's marginally more expensive so
but but let's let's get down to brass
tacks here the specs look very very much
the same same camera front and back uh
this displays is the same they say they
have a DOT what does this a DOT drop
display not the same as the the what
what are your what did your what is what
does random phone have is it um
water drop is that different no no well
yeah I mean it's like I mean uh is it
different I mean they I think that's
their name for for just it again I
haven't looked at like the A9 specs
really so why is it more money why is it
more money
um well one to to
Source all the uh the parts of this
device
um we you know it does cost more money
to be able to get the parts we get from
because if you don't want a supply chain
reliant on you know let's say CCP
companies or whatever it ends up being a
little bit more expensive a little bit
more pricey um and also when you do
things at scale the overall product ends
up being cheaper so when people look up
the price of these phones uh you know a
lot of these prices it's for ordering
you know 50 000 units at once because
companies did and they can sell it
because it's exactly yeah yeah so or
another company does it and then yeah
they resell it at that cost so they're
the the root cause of the phone is
they're selling fifty thousand or a
hundred thousand phones and then yeah
they either resell
um or or you know that it counts as as
buying a hundred thousand phones or
something um or what what does the
operating system do because because look
regardless of the reason why it costs
you more money like why should someone
spend more money on a phone that has
effectively the same specs as the A9
well yeah I mean at the operating system
level I mean we I mean if you buy that
if you buy that phone I guarantee it has
a ton of Google stuff on I mean not just
guarantee you can look it up um it has a
ton of Google stuff on it it uses the
Google Play store which totally tracks
you and it's uh the supply chain has not
been verified
um and all that and we're gonna post on
you know our whole supply chain process
which I think on on our website
um coming up and then we just we just
got out there and it was like a crazy
launch so you know we just we we
honestly did not expect to honestly have
it kind of blow up this much but it but
is it right now is that basically like
the freedom OS yeah Freedom OS is a mix
of uh lineage AOSP Android open source
lineage OS graphene OS couple other
custom roms and our own touch and uh so
one of the things we do on this phone is
we Silo every app in its own little
digital Island its own little digital
bubble so that way it can't see anything
that's going on the rest oh that's
awesome yeah exactly so sandboxing yeah
sandboxing so uh uh you know like right
now and I and I think in even Apple
developer analytics just as a normal
developer you're able to see yeah yeah
you don't have YouTube on the phone do
you uh no no YouTube is uh uh you you
have the option you don't annoys me what
when I'll try I'll be using the browser
on my phone and I'll go to Reddit and
then it pulls up the app instead oh
that's it keeps telling you to do it and
there's been periods where I've had to
do like I've been out right so like I'll
record everything and then I'll leave
and then I'll get a notification from
like someone message me and be like oh
hey there was a typo in the in the the
thumbnail or something or typo in the in
the title so I'll have to go in to the
to the to make changes but every time I
go to the browser to try and log into
the browser it pulls up the YouTube app
and then not the actual like studio so I
have to I have to actually delete the
YouTube app because the apps all connect
to each other exactly the browser should
be independent from other apps if I'm in
the browser and I need to pulp a site
for a specific reason and I I can't
remember the specific reason but I I
think it's because um the YouTube studio
app doesn't actually allow you to affect
I think monetization you have to go into
the browser to do it but then the
browser default pulls up the YouTube app
not even the studio app and then I can't
go in so I delete YouTube from my phone
log in fix it then reinstall you might
be able to fix that in settings and have
it so it doesn't Auto default to the app
yeah ultimately that's what I oh good
I'm doing yeah something like that like
don't switch are there oh sorry
um are there have you guys looked into
setting up anything that allows you to
mine cryptocurrency on your phone while
it's active the problem with that is uh
I mean we could you know give you the
option do that but your phone is uh it
doesn't have this headphone has a great
processor but for literal like Bitcoin
mining that takes like a huge amount of
processing could you tap into a mesh
Network and be part of a group of nodes
that we're mining I don't think the
money would end up being worth it for
you so yeah you could but I don't think
it'd be worth it for you 500 bucks a
steep man 4.99
um yeah I mean uh you know we give
coupon codes for 50 bucks off and you
people can pay monthly if they want to
and all that but but yeah I mean to me I
mean you know you see the phone feels as
good I mean you have a thousand dollar
iPhones even thirteen hundred dollar
iPhones we didn't want to like cheap out
on it might be in the quality you know
I'm thinking about it because I'm like I
understand you know some of the
arguments people make they're like dude
the A9 is cheap and I'm like if I wanted
to buy the phone right now and I wanted
to get someone without them having to
worry about it I want to get them a
phone that's not being tracked that's
got these these these apps that have
been censored they can get access to
that's going to be hard for me to do
like like I'm thinking you know what if
I were to just buy a hundred of these
a9s and then just go through them and
then load up a new operating system
there'd have to be so much stuff you'd
have to do to make sure it works and
quality control I probably won't be able
to do that I gotta be honest I think 500
bucks sounds sounds steep but I stand by
what I was saying earlier that
if if your device does what it says it
does and you're providing a service
effectively Hardware be damned if it's a
service that provides people with
instant access to a clean operating
system that doesn't track them and
provides them a way around censorship
that's seriously that's it's massive
also you're not using slave labor right
yeah no no and that's that's another
thing is just yeah I mean to me I feel
like the real story of this is that you
know what like apple like I always
thought it'd be great if um if if some
president had put sanctions on on the
import of any goods made by slave labor
because that would just shut down a lot
of these big phone companies and and
hold everything up because it's bad yeah
but then the American people would be
like why does my phone cost 10 grand
I mean you know I think well trust me we
make this phone what isn't it doesn't
have to it doesn't have to cost that
much if if you're not using using that
kind of Labor and all that oh yeah yeah
Hong Kong is has got problems right now
but I don't uh yeah they're not well
actually I don't know for sure foxconn's
on Hong Kong they're in they're in
Taiwan they're in Taiwan really yeah
yeah well they have they have they have
stuff from all of them I mean exactly
Fox gun is in Taiwan I believe they're a
Taiwanese company fact check me New York
Times fact check me right now Eric yeah
isn't an iPhone like a thousand dollars
yeah exactly an iPhone I thought it was
okay you're right yeah that's why the
people are committing suicide yeah yeah
okay good I'm glad because I was like I
was like I like Taiwan you know and all
that and I was like no yeah I thought it
was yeah New York Times fact check me
but yeah I mean with the phone at the
operating system level yeah it's
completely de-googled you know it has
its own app store and all that so you're
not relying on the Google Play store or
anything and uh and we you know like you
know trying to side load apps or all
that for I mean the thing about this
phone is a lot of just normal people
that aren't aren't like yeah trying to
jailbreak their phones root their phones
and all that got that and then yeah I
mean that's that's
it's just a huge problem that we're
reliant on in my opinion anti-free
speech Hardware I mean it's ironic to me
that Apple's motto used to be think
different and now they ban apps who
think different
um and uh uh so I mean it's or Google
which was do no evil and then now
there's company policy they got rid of
that motto and all that and that's and
that's why I think you know like you
know we're a startup But ultimately and
uh and I I don't have like a PR team of
like a thousand people like these people
like I'm just you know coming on this
podcast you know
um uh you know just trying to share the
word
um but I mean it's it's it's it's just
if we don't have our own hardware and my
opinion we're screwed it's the weirdest
thing that people were like it's saying
it's a Honeypot like yeah the phone is a
trap I'm like what do you think your
phone already does exactly welcome to
modern technology
they wouldn't attack me this much if it
was and then two yeah I mean they've
docked unless they're trying to convince
everyone you're on the level by
attacking you saying see look they're
attacking him that must prove it
because of these articles and because of
will Summers article my mom got doxed
and all that and they're releasing that
is a coordinated harassment campaign
from will summer in my opinion and uh uh
and I mean and and it's just I mean
luckily my mom's Scottish so she's tough
um she was tough growing up um in the
best way possible
um and uh and they've dodged my own
because my mom she worked on the I mean
she's an incredibly smart woman and and
a great mother uh she uh she worked on
the um the Star Wars project under
Reagan
um and all that and then yeah so they're
trying to say like on this honey pot and
all that just because my mom you know
worked worked on a project under the
Reagan Administration and all that and
uh I mean it's it's crazy honestly that
that my mom has gone to I mean coming to
the political world I almost like I I
mean I knew what was coming in the sense
of of you know but I was so well liked
by the left-wing media you know I was
doing interviews with them and all that
and I was fine I want to give it up
because for free speech and all that I
mean it sounds cheesy but it's actually
true
um and uh but to me to see like yeah my
mom get doxed you know these people
write fake articles
um and uh for people that hadn't even
touched the phone yet I mean it's it's
amazing when I think about how we got to
this point you know I was talking about
I'm still Shell Shocked honestly like
you know I was talking about algorithmic
uh psychosis and I want I'm thinking
about it from like their the perspective
of the Psychopaths and who live in the
in the mirror world in the in the in the
in the upside down or whatever
and you know how did how did we come to
this position of knowing computers of no
like look we knew about Bitcoin in the
early days most people didn't even find
out about Bitcoin until like 2016 or
something and I'm like I was on the
internet
as long as I can remember my family had
CompuServe on dos you know and then so
then we got Windows 3.1 we had AOL
I've always had access to the internet
to learn and read whatever I wanted and
I guess that makes uh uh that makes you
a deviant because you have access to the
summation of human knowledge or so so
much knowledge at the time regular
people other Millennials didn't get the
internet until they were teenagers so
they didn't necessarily grow up with it
as heavily like I was programming stuff
I was doing video games I was I was
doing flash animations and Flash
websites when I was like 12 or 13. it's
amazing yeah I built my first computer
when I was like seven so here I am with
all the access to this information
totally independent these other people
don't and I think that that might be
where this like hard bifurcation starts
the people who are internet Savvy who
understand the rules of the internet
don't argue with trolls it means they
win
but then you get these other kids who
aren't internet Savvy and they're just
watching nothing but this horror content
and so they become insane and we become
discerning
mm-hmm and then you get tough to say
because me and Eric are both we're like
almost different Generations I'm 42
you're 22. yeah I'm 20 years apart
that's crazy we're both internet dudes
like I didn't get internet until I was
16 AOL but I'm still here was that
1996 or four or five or something 1994
what year were you born 79 79 yeah so
right right around there you look like a
product of the 70s yeah I feel like man
just barely but it's the critical
thinking skills and I don't know if it
matters when you were born if you're
going to have critical thinking skills
realizing what you see isn't necessarily
like if you see something a thousand
times that doesn't mean that it happened
a thousand times I don't know what do
you
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
just think that there's two um different
universes that exist yeah it seems like
there are people who live in the
paranoid you know it's really funny uh
there's this very very high profile
podcaster who apparently um said that I
was one of these people who lit who's
two two online
and uh you know like oh there's these
these people they're just two online and
they live in this world and I'm like
the people on the left
who believe in all of this algorithmic
psychosis and are completely unaware of
it
they're the people who are too online
the people who believe that Donald Trump
was a Russian agent that's because of
the two online people I I'm afraid that
it's their lack of critical thinking
skills and if they just watched a lot of
like violent action movies they they
think that that was normal too
they're they've they've been how do you
how do you tell someone who's spent 15
years of their 25-year life that
everything they've seen and experienced
on social media as they were growing up
and learned was wrong you encouraged
them to take suicide here's here's an
example imagine you're in an aircraft
hangar massive we're talking like 50 80
000 square feet this massive aircraft
hangar
and we're all looking around at stuff
constantly walking over and asking
what's that oh that's interesting and
these people are in the corner staring
at this the corner of the room pointing
thinking that's reality it's almost like
the allegory of the of the Shadows in
the cave yeah yeah yeah yeah that
they've been sitting in this cave seeing
nothing but police brutality shadow
puppets
and so when you're at the door of the
cave yelling that's not real life
they're like you're crazy these people
are conspiracy theorists it's a rabbit
hole you know it's like what I can't
remember the exact quote from Breitbart
about walking towards the fire but uh
you know uh
people think I can't remember the exact
quote but someone said to me something
similar so it might not be Breitbart
that people are scared to walk towards
the facts I think they'll get burned but
the other side is freedom and you know
you walk past it and then everything's
normal and you're fine these people are
trapped in the cave man yeah because the
Shadows on the wall it is real life it's
just one tiny fragment of real life
right exactly so they're living in this
paranoid delusional State they look look
at what they say when they're like when
they say when they say things like
police are hunting black people jeez you
we know that's not real but imagine
you're 18 and you were eight years old
and you had no no life experience you
were playing hopscotch a few years later
you get on Facebook the first time and
what do you see remember that book we
had with um azra yeah yeah the CRT book
it was the book where the little kid was
like seeing a video on the internet like
eight-year-old kid and then and then
saying like Mommy what's this the mom's
like No don't watch this and then the
little girl finally snaps one day like I
know the truth about what the police are
doing
it's because people realize you'll make
money off of police brutality videos oh
I think I figured out how to get through
to these people or maybe something that
can help is my mom I used to play video
games a lot my mom would be like it's
not real this isn't real this isn't but
what she didn't realize is if she just
told me this is real but there's more
look these are also things that are real
so acknowledge that what I was doing
Israel like if I'm playing a video game
and it's a character and a story in my
mind that is reality it's just a
fragment of this greater reality so if
you acknowledge like critical race all
these theories and things yeah they are
real they're they are valid Concepts but
there's more there's a there's a meme
where it's like there's this guy playing
video games and then his dad walks in
and he goes hey do you want to play this
cool new game basically you have to go
on adventures you try and raise money to
buy certain to buy artifacts and items
to improve your character's stats become
better equipped stronger and faster you
make friends and then and he's like yeah
you make friends along the way and the
dude's like wow sounds awesome and then
he shoves them out the door and he's
like have fun
it's life dude life imitates art and all
that stuff you know
shall we read super chats yes let's go
let's read on the super chat if you
haven't already give that uh like button
a little tap subscribe to this Channel
and become a member at timcast.com so
that we can hire more and more and more
journalists the next person we're gonna
hire is probably the fact Checker and
their whole job is going to be just to
read the website and then yell at us
yeah and then they're gonna it's gonna
they're gonna have like a a uh this is
gonna be New York Times fact check level
though it's gonna be like
no so I'm I'm we're gonna we're gonna be
like so strict with our fact checking
good like not even just checking facts
but also checking framing like if
someone says you know Ian is is uh Ian
Ian Crossland comma the absurdly skinny
co-host from Tim cast IRL comma would be
like absurdly skinny that's that's poor
framing we gotta you know it's opinion
and call him skinny I guess but absurdly
like we don't need those adjectives in
these so I actually had an email someone
emailed me saying they were upset about
an article not upset but they're like
hey this article is like really loaded
and I went and saw it I was like oh geez
and I had to go and I went in and
immediately issued a correction like
none of that loaded garbage so we're
actually
um
planning on covering a lot of the
election invest Audits and stuff like
that and uh so we're going to have like
the statements from the Democrats and
what they've been saying about it safer
from the Republicans but we're not going
to play stupid games with Framing and
adjectives or it's going to be like
here's what they're saying here's what
they're saying you decide let's read
these super chats all right let's see
the curly Afro says for women being
drafted proved they're a separate
separated lightweight quick moving Force
integrated forces is horrible idea for
reasons as a former FMF Hospital
corpsman third class sexual assault is a
giant issue and problem in the military
for both genders yeah wow
velvet schwinter says Freedom phone is
as good of a phone as Linwood is a
lawyer
okay that's pretty good that's hilarious
honestly The Dashing Rogue says is the
freedom phone the Uma Digi A9 Pro I
believe it's actually just the Uma Digi
A9 or comparable 2. that's the specs
that I pulled up uh we have slightly
different specs you can look at the
specs from freedomphone.com and there's
a Specs button right in the nav bar so
feel free to look at it it's a custom
phone
um and that has different parts but no
and and obviously the different
operating system as well they say I read
your company's privacy policy and I'm
wondering if you sell your company where
does my data go where does it did it go
so yeah I mean all that we do in our
privacy policy is we say hey we track uh
uh just your name and your address if
you buy a phone and that's it so uh if
uh if you want to do like a return and
one I don't want to sell and then two uh
even if somehow you know that happened
and one I I really don't think I will
um even if somehow that happened uh you
know it would just be your name and the
address if there's like a return or
something and those are all kept private
all right Warframe for the win says does
the Freedom phone have physical hardware
switches like the pine phone and Librium
5.
um no that's something we want to add we
feel very confident like you can
literally go in at you know in your
settings and in a much better way just
like literally turn things off uh we
want to be able to add that um but I
think the problem with those other
phones although I like I like anyone
doing honestly uh some a secure phone uh
uh uh it's that's something we want to
do but yeah the problem we want to make
a phone that was usable and and calling
that was one of the the first things
that when making a privacy Security
phone is that it was usable for a normal
person and I tried out all the Privacy
phones and a big problem was although
they were secure so I love that I love
that part but they just weren't usable
so that that kind of ended up affecting
the usability and at the operating
system level we we just feel so
confident but I think that's something
we want to add in the few maybe a
freedom phone too what's the problem
with the usability with those
um it just ended up making it like super
insanely bulky
um and that was a problem like
physically large yeah physically large
so that was a problem on our side and it
didn't really fit in the hand well so we
had like a bunch of prototypes at our
Design Lab
um and so we ended up going with this
option as the best option we felt very
confident the operating system level
security was good enough right on and
we're gonna oh real quick we're gonna
open source actually the operating
system coming up as well so that way
people can look at it cool
Studio says hey guys just join
timcast.com today love the content are
there any plans to be able to cast to
Chromecast Etc we want to watch on TV
yes so
there's only so much people can do uh
the website is launched we're doing the
bug checks now making sure everything
works because you know it's like you fix
one bug and then 10 more pop up and then
you're playing whack-a-mole for a bit
then we're gonna do the mobile app
because we want to make sure people can
listen to the show while their screen is
off
and then we're going to be doing what's
called Ott over the top so that's like
Roku players Apple TV Amazon all that
stuff you'll be able to pull up the
shows so we're heading in that direction
and we also are planning on doing more
and more content right now if you
remember you get the members only
podcast episodes when the next week or
so we're gonna have a new show which is
going to be I just call it like
Mysteries and spooky stories but you'll
see the launch and we're working on the
graphics and The Branding and all the
stuff
all right let's see
Jonathan Duggar says not naming that
other production when confronted about
it is not a good look and it seemed like
a deflection seems a little shady
referring to the factory if the other
Factory I literally post on the website
after this it's just uh it's just in a
name I can't pronounce like it's
literally that and we just had it you
know so it's like it sounds straight
it's like I can't say the Asian word I
can't say it so I feel like I feel like
that's it I'll put it up on the website
for anyone that's concerned so I guess
uh I guess I I guess I have a little bit
of an ego I don't like looking stupid
but you should write it on a card just
like hold it up right in a car yeah
Lua coder says Tim there are certain
Samsung phones that are bootloader
locked and you cannot install custom
operating systems some people are stuck
with that yes I've experienced that
that's annoying
all right let's see
Brenton Dean says this phone comes out
right after the story of intelligence
agencies making and distributing the
same type of ghost phones to a crime
ring and this is being sold as the
perfect phone for dissidents not suspect
at all
yeah I mean this goes back to like this
week I mean that's why it's just overall
it's been weird I guess to weird and
amazing to get in in my opinion the
political realm like yeah just like
people accusing my mom of of you know
basically being deep State and helping
me with this I mean that's that's the
kind of stuff that that that it's weird
to experience because I don't think that
they would be attacking me this time I
guess again you're right maybe there's
you know it's a double cross or whatever
but I mean I like I I'm funding this
whole thing myself so I have like no
other investors know anything I mean the
CIA literally has a venture arm and all
that which is not a lot of people know
that
um but yeah I mean honestly I I I I
would be living a much better life I
feel if they were if they were
supportive of me um and I would never
accept that I just gotta shout this out
right now someone's uh Soleil cucumber
lime says if you use Brave browser there
is a setting to allow video playback in
the background AKA this with a screen
off oh we did mention that before
someone super chatted this I use the
brave browser for everything Brave is
amazing
that's the default browser on the phone
yeah yeah there you go yeah Brave is the
default browser.go default search engine
it's right on the home screen I love
Brave yeah Oscar olyou says Eric if you
want people to trust you you need to
release the source code for Freedom OS
and have it available for compiling Ian
would you say free the code I would like
to free the code yeah I mean the goal is
is to be able so you know yeah we want
to like like I said earlier we're going
to be open sourcing the uh the operating
system code on this and then yeah I mean
if you want to be able to uh not even go
through us you know and all that and uh
and get your own you know install it
yourself and go through that difficult
process you know you can do that for
free oh so you could you you're going to
open well that's the plan yeah people
can just take and do it I mean to me
this the phone is just about making it
easy for people so it's all in one
device so you don't have to be good at
you know have you looked at um using
like an MIT license like a copy left
license so that if people take the code
and change it those changes have to
remain free also oh that's a good idea
actually we should do that for that
because to me that would be the most
important thing is that you know people
weren't you know that way they can make
it just continues on zanrov says the
spec site says it uses Freedom OS but
when I Google what that is I get a logo
that looks similar to the red salute
that's Troublesome at face value am I
missing something yeah that's a
different
um uh operating system I think that's I
think that's Linux based um and all that
but yeah I mean that's just a different
one that's I believe open source as well
um and all that and then yeah it has the
red fist ours is a blue shield on a
phone it's really interesting there's a
lot of super chances I'm scrolling
through that you literally just answered
like yay God says can we jailbreak our
own Android phones and flash your custom
ROM and effectively do the same thing
with our existing phones that's the plan
and hopefully for you know when we
release this I mean we just want to get
this out there and then yeah I guess
there's maybe been some marketing
greenness if you will
um but yeah I mean you know peop people
sent us a lot of requests us like hey
can you open source this and be like
yeah I mean the goal is to be able to
have anyone be you know have the ability
to flash uh you know to be able to be
secure and have all that I mean we
incorporate a lot of stuff at the uh you
know kind of that Hardware software
marriage on our own phone but yeah I
mean the goal is to be able where if you
want to be able to uh flash on if your
Tech if you have the technical know-how
to flash it on your phone you can do
that for free that's the plan
Qui-Gon says Kevin Smith lied He-Man
died F Hollywood well I haven't watched
the new master of the universe but I
guess people are like saying like he
wrote the Kevin Smith ruined it
apparently pilas the Sorceress of gray
skull that's like the female lead
character she was kind of like a side
character in the original He-Man but now
apparently she's like one of those what
does that mean that means like she has
the power now I don't know I didn't look
into it it just it looked so weird like
he-man's the Beast
he is Prince Adam I love you you look
like Prince Adam yeah honestly it's been
interesting because uh uh you know I
remember I did a uh back when I was
liked by the left-wing media I did a New
York Magazine thing and then they made
me look so nerd they made me look so
nerdy they comb my hair to the side
maybe button up my shirt and look like a
total nerd um I guess I am a nerd at
heart I went to a a photo shoot once for
Spin Magazine and they wanted me to look
a certain way and the first and the
first thing was like okay now take off
the beanie and I was like no I'm not
doing no it's the look and then she was
like you have to we're not doing the
shoot and I was like I stood up grabbed
my bag and I was like all right I looked
at my friend I'm like I get the door and
then she goes wait wait what are you
doing and I was like I'm leaving she's
like but we're doing a shoot and I'm
like that's staying on it she goes
there's only one person I've ever let
keep the head on and it's the edge and
you are not the edge and then I was like
okay and then I started walking towards
the door again she goes fine and then I
went back and sat down modeling sucks
man yeah I mean doing photo shoots I
know they like they make your body in a
weird pose they're like pull your back
up now twist your arm to the right and
like then they put Clips all over your
back and you're like and then you make
like now don't move for a minute and I'm
like it's like the bed it's painful if
you can't breathe it's a job honestly
it's a job no lifestyle it's a lifestyle
you gotta watch what you eat that's
annoying I can't do that here's a good
one Mike Tasha says piracy is
small-scale communism you take away the
means of production from the original
Creator and give it to any idiot that
can click a link it dilutes the essence
of the work yeah interesting I actually
think Communists should be mad about
piracy too like if there is a dude and
he's like I have designed this this
great image and would you like to buy it
no picture picture now everyone has a
version of it you're like but I work so
hard to make this do I am I not
deserving of access to food and and and
and and well people love being your
information doesn't mean you can't sell
it that's the that's the how am I
supposed to understand value comes from
the scarcity of of the object no no not
necessarily scarcity is involved in that
but also quality
so if somebody
makes something and then everybody just
has it why would someone give him money
if everyone has it that means it's
probably something that needs to be
Commons like a song
no Commons is in common license so like
I write a song like common like and then
it took it took it took what like it
took us several months to make will of
the people right so and so for me that
was kind of just like you know a side
project
I'm not worried about losing money on it
it was expensive we're not going to make
a million bucks after anything but maybe
there's a hope like oh maybe it'll sell
we'll make money but we're in a new era
honestly like people listen to that on
YouTube but all of that work we put into
that if it was any other person and they
took off time uh from their like this is
their job
and it's entertainment people value it
and they want it and then everyone gets
it for free how does he get the money to
buy the instruments how does he get the
money to pay for the recording process
how does he do more you sell the song
for 99 cents a download that doesn't
mean it just because a million more
people get it for free doesn't mean
you're not going to be able to sell a
bunch of more copies of the song that's
a million dollars it literally does yeah
but those people may not have bought it
you in fact usually when people copy
things for free it's because they can't
afford things and I think that
proliferation percentage of people who
would have bought it who don't maybe you
don't know but I think proliferating the
information that's true I think they're
proliferating the information makes
people more excited for that information
for the regular person who says if it
costs me 10 grand to work to produce
this song I at least need to make 10
grand back and then everyone copies it
and shares it online and now the guy
makes no money his business ceases to
exist it actually happened with uh with
Kick Ass kick ass 3 got shut down
because Kick-Ass 2 got pirated so much
that they said we didn't recuperate our
losses we're not going to do another
movie it's not worth it and a cage was
in the first one right he was he was in
the first one my understanding is it
didn't do well enough
it was like people liked it and we could
do another one the second one was like
people liked it ah but everybody pirate
it we didn't make enough money we don't
care to do it and the movie sucked so
kickass2 didn't suck well you just said
it was like yeah that sucks I'm talking
about the revenue I thought kick ass one
and two were awesome I I would have
loved to see part three like you don't
problem is people pirated it and then
they didn't make enough money so they
didn't want to do it again I you don't
want people to to copy and sell your
content it's not about selling it's
about if if they're gonna invest 100
million dollars in a movie they at least
need to make a hundred million dollars
now I know Hollywood plays dirty games
with how they calculate revenue and
everything like that but what happens is
they go how much did we get back on this
we got pirated like crazy so people like
it they do but we're not making money
scrap it now I don't get to watch a
movie I like because people didn't want
to pay for it I don't even think
pirating things means that people like
it I don't like that word pirate right I
liked the movie and people pirated it so
now I don't get to yeah but them copying
the the movie doesn't mean that they
like the movie they just what does that
have to do with anything you just said
that a hundred million people so they
like it that doesn't I like I didn't say
that I said I liked the movie and then
people pirated it so now I don't get to
see the sequel
I think artists being able to make money
is just it's just really important and I
think you know I understand if people
can't afford but then you know I feel
like if the artist wants it to be
available for free you know that should
be his choice rather than rather than uh
uh you know just some guy and again
there's I feel like a lot of it's just a
lot of people trying to cheap out and
ten percent of it this is an inherently
like
I wouldn't even call this a leftist
world view because the left hates the
idea of exploitation of the working
class this is just like
what we're doing with the fativerse
project is an act of Charity in a sense
that I can uh plan out funding for a
project and people can donate their time
to it to give something for free to a
lot of people
but there's a lot of people we've
already had this conversation who need
to work full time to make this thing
happen Okay I can and will provide
funding to make sure we make the world a
better place
because I'm not worried about it Tim
Cass is successful and that means what
are we going to do where like I said I
don't want to buy a Ferrari I want to
make the fediverse app so that people
can live better lives and have their
speech and their rights protected
now as for that person who's going to do
the hard coding he needs to eat food he
needs to actually have a house I have to
give him money to do it
what if he said okay I'm gonna work on a
project that's going to make everyone's
lives lives a lot better and he didn't
have access to funding
who's going to pay for it if everyone
just takes the code and then rips it
from him how can he actually work 40
hours a week and then get nothing back
for it because it's not stealing to take
his hard work from him this is what I'm
talking about you need a technical
solution because people are going to
copy information it's never going to
stop sure the whole idea of an artist
being able to make money it didn't exist
until the 1920s until radio you couldn't
you couldn't cat there was no mass media
a singer musician would have to go play
shows at an end every night to make
dinner
any industry I'm talking about
entertainment that has nothing to do
with it movies and TV digital art it's
that didn't exist 150 years ago it's new
art healing architecture Blueprints and
and copying them and pasting them is the
same thing no it's very different
stealing someone's blueprints is very
different than making a copy of them
what
I'm literally talking about if someone
designs a building and comes up with
engineering practices and then people
start copying it and sharing it all
around and that guy doesn't get
compensation for it he won't be able to
keep innovating his career is done this
will starve then he will lose his life
the point you're making that I agree
with is that if he's not getting caught
if they're copying his art and then
selling it and he's not getting
compensated that's a problem that we
need to put into the code that you need
to be able to follow where the data came
from so that the original Creator gets a
portion of the sales and if there's no
sales because they're just copying it
then what's the harm
the guy can't make more music
well it's up to the guy it's not up to
the people that are copying the
information if the guy continues to make
music reports in front of his mouth they
weren't gonna buy it anyway they copied
it because they couldn't buy it why are
you assuming they were weren't going to
buy it clearly somebody who like it
would have I don't think either of us
should assume that it would have been
sold just because someone made a copy of
doesn't mean that they would have bought
it revenues literally dropped when
Napster came out people actually saw
revenues go down now I don't care about
multi-millionaire celebrities but when
we're talking about a regular
hard-working person you like his work
you want his work to continue but then
everyone just copies instead of buying
it that's a problem
yeah but everyone does not copy instead
of buy that's the situation so the
revenues dropped and we we actually saw
this for a lot of a lot of people I I
dude I have friends who lost their jobs
around this time okay the Market's
changing actors are severely overpaid
musicians get paid millions in the 90s
millions millions were ridiculous my
friends like I've produced this short
film I would like to show it to you if I
can get everyone to pay me a dollar to
watch it I can continue to do work and
they said meh I'll just digitally copy
it yeah you think that making a movie
should make you a millionaire I mean you
think that these actors should be
getting 30 million dollars for a movie
that's Insanity in you are clearly
getting triggered because what your
argument is makes no sense I'm telling
you the reality of the world right now I
know you're just saying that oh no they
shouldn't do that that shouldn't be so
let's make it illegal and punish people
like when did I say that you're saying
that they shouldn't be able to make the
copies what that was wrong they went
after those guys it's wrong okay I said
when they gave that guy a massive fine
start going to people's houses I said
that was wrong it was insane it's like
the 3D we're talking like 3D printers
like it's very simple morality that what
piracy was destroying the the the
livelihoods of the people who made the
work no it was maybe reducing their
income but it was not destroying their
livelihoods there are a lot of people
who lost their jobs over this who
friends of mine possibly not possibly
literally people like the whole industry
automation is many people are going to
lose their jobs because the automation
is taking it away and and you know you
know what's funny is that they already
solved for this problem you're defending
something doesn't exist anymore for the
most part no I'm trying to fall I'm
trying to solve Amazon Plus Netflix all
of these Services have solved for that
problem and revenues came back it was a
bad thing that happened my friend once
sent me a video saying please share this
and it was a PSA about like all the
people who had lost their jobs in the
industry Pas been making 12 bucks an
hour because their Studios were
downsizing after they they couldn't turn
a profit on making short films because
those Studios were overblown people were
doing right here yeah people seem to
think that movies are only Blockbusters
but see I have friends who were Pas and
worked in the industry and a lot of
movies are actually low budget short
films there is a massive amount of low
low cost dramas and comedies now that
special effects is getting better we're
starting to see low budget sci-fi and
fantasy and then at the cream of the
crap the top of the top what you see is
Marvel movies my friends were working on
low budget films that cost 100 Grand
they lost their jobs because these
things would get posted online and then
shared and nobody would would want to
pay for it dude that's that all got
solved that's because of digital I mean
there's a hundred how many more Movie
Makers are there now than there were 30
years ago because it's it's more
accessible you can buy buy a three
thousand dollar camera spend like four
grand on audio equipment and make an
incredible we're gonna move back because
I don't think you're actually you're
arguing anything anymore
Aya bat says Eric love the freedom phone
you should consider preloading them with
a z cash wallet I think you know Z cash
is right yeah yeah yeah Z catches a
cryptocurrency with the strongest
privacy guarantees also has encrypted
messaging feature yes Z cash shout out
I'm a huge cash fan
um monero's good but Z cash is I I love
Z cash
um and that's a great idea actually
all right let's see
the Raptor's Talent says Ian I get that
you're trying to play Devil's Advocate
stop it you're trying to use nonsense to
argue with facts piracy in the context
of the internet is not simply theft of
content it is theft of income by copy
pasting onto the internet you are
robbing them of their ability to make
money you're assuming that because
someone made a copy that they would have
bought it that is an assumption
we know for a fact revenues went down
right
yeah some revenues that means they did
lose Metallica lost some of their
hundreds of millions yeah but but ignore
the fact that you know who metallic is
you don't know who like Jimmy's basement
barbecue it all says yeah people lost
income it's also cheaper to make movies
so that's that's that's announcing it's
equalizer you make less for your sales
and you spend less to make the thing
all right let's read some more
Andrew Lance says Freedom phone dude
please give me the hard sell my iPhone
is about to turn two so the built-in
obsolescence will come can you promise
that my phone will still function well
five years from now
yeah I mean you can that's I feel
confident about that your phone will
last for five years um and all that I
mean we make these phones to last I mean
obviously if you're throwing it in water
or anything like that I mean it's not
and then we also have a very generous
return policy as well so I mean um but
yeah I mean these phones we make them to
last for a long time because we know
phones will do it but I mean if you end
up being really rough if you're working
in the if you're trying to take it to
space or something yeah it's not gonna
laugh but yeah I mean it should last
like a like I I I feel my opinion this
will last for five years I mean the Hard
Sell on it is um is if you want a phone
that uh has all like has its own app
store which has all the normal apps your
normal phone has plus band ones as well
if you want a phone that cares about
your privacy cares about your security
and feel free to anyone that wants to
you know test it out feel free to do it
and we're going to be posting videos
soon
um of the testing that we've done we
want to put like a top-notch hacker and
just I mean we've done this internally
but actually publicly make like a little
video about it of them trying to get
into this phone and I'm sure this is
what people people are going to do when
they when the phone is is as shipped out
to everybody but yeah I mean that's the
hard sell I mean that we're just trying
to challenge the app on Google duopoly
here all right Weston Hecker says does
the phone have its own baseband software
or modifications to the Hal Hardware
access layer
otadm or any other stuff aside from the
custom OS uh I should get my CTO on the
phone because because that's over my
head I hired a white hack white hat guy
uh that has been my friend for years I
mean he built this out so we're going to
be posting on uh you know we're gonna
have freedomphone.com security that goes
into literally all the things that we
did on the security front
BlackRock beacon says algorithmic
psychosis is an availability Cascade
driven by confirmation bias and virtue
signaling reinforced by gamification or
human interaction
well there you go
all right
what is this the Logan Culver says Tim
how many of the normal chats are from
Bots LOL I don't know uh we we made it
so that you got to be a subscriber to
use the chat though and a lot of people
were like I don't like that and I'm like
too bad if you're not subscribed to the
channel like why are you I don't
understand what the issue is like you
come to the show and watch the point of
the subscriber chat was to get rid of a
lot of the spam because spam Bots come
in don't subscribe and then so I was
like okay that solves that
easy right crazy
all right let's see
Daniel Nelson says sign me up having my
browser redirected to apartment.com
repeatedly of my exact location when
trying to send a political message was
my wake-up call not cool leave US
citizens alone
well there you go
all right let's see sewer turd says can
the phone be picked up in person to
avoid possible tampering and Route by a
third party
right now we ship it to you and we uh we
put a little tracker
um to make sure it got got to you and
all that um not a tracker on the phone
but just like uh we put on the outside
of the box so that way we make sure that
they're saying and then we've got a seal
as well so that way if anyone has opened
the phone you would know by the time it
gets there and then man I'll tell you
this I've had more than enough of my uh
of my time at the tamper uh evident
Village in Defcon to know how to get
past those seals you know that's true
have you ever been there uh Defcon yeah
I've been once you get like the Little
Steamer thing and then you steam the
sticker and the two and you get the
tweezers and you peel the sticker back
and you can pop it right open go inside
then close it and put the tamper evident
thing back and we also put it in in its
own case as well so it comes like on
this one I don't have it on this is just
what I bring around to show people I I
got an idea have people send you their
fingerprints then you can pre-load the
fingerprint so only they can open it
that's perfectly safe well yeah I don't
wanna I don't wanna have to have people
submit their fingerprints it's not gonna
happen
all right let's see
there was just a Super Chat that jumped
away from me let's try and find it
Smokey says anyone who thinks these
phones can't be tracked as an idiot
anything with an electronic signature
can be tracked
we put the operating system level and it
it turns it off at the hardware level
um uh we put the options a button a
virtual button to be able to turn off
and it really does turn it off on the
phone
um everything and out of the box like so
many phones they they come with like
Wi-Fi and Bluetooth already on and
that's one of the vulnerabilities that
that people can kind of get into your
phone with so we make sure it turns all
of those things off when you get it w
couch says does freedom phone support
right to repair and can I change my own
battery can you change your own battery
I mean yeah you're welcome to uh it's if
you're in our in our in our policy
you're yeah you have totally the ability
to uh repaired on your own on the
battery is in there um and all that so
if you want your like your battery if
it's a problem you'd have to ship it to
us
um but I mean if you're able to figure
that out on your own that's totally it
doesn't break our warranty policy
all right
yeah if you break you know player uh
player FTW says question for Eric if
this has been asked before I apologize
will there be a less pricey version of
the freedom phone 500 is a bit steep for
some uh well you can get uh any coupon
code online 50 bucks I don't want to
like plug it here to you know or
anything but yeah so it's pretty easy if
you if you can go anywhere you can
pretty much get 50 bucks off and and
look it up and that makes it 449 is that
one of the codes oh yeah posto is one of
the codes and all that so if you I
bought I bought I bought the slippers
from my pillow oh yeah and I was like
you know considering the smear pieces
I'm like I bet post is one of the codes
yeah and what was it
we have a lot of code so you really can
get it for 449
um if uh if you just use any of those
codes and um uh but yeah I mean the goal
is is to you know be able to the more
that the more sales that we could get
the more we can get the parts cheaper as
well so
um yeah we hope to make it cheaper and
we've been growing at a great rate so we
think we can um but you know it might be
a sec
oh apparently I think we have the let me
see if I can fix this someone said the
description is the wrong link
no it looks good that's right
freedomfone.com freedomphone.com yeah
yeah that time
freedom.com that is the correct link and
what's the other one there's another one
people are mentioning yeah there's like
I think like a freedom dot dash
phones.net or something that's a
different thing okay so it's just
freedomphone.com okay
all right Jay dubski says Eric check out
Rob braxman he's a tech expert against
tracking and censorship I would love to
see a review of your phone on his
YouTube channel yeah I mean if he wants
to review unit tell him to reach out to
us Big Mac attack says hey Tim I'd like
to be able to pay for an MP3 version of
your will of the People song tongue
clicks do you know the way in the
description of the of the video will of
the people on YouTube is a link to
bandcamp where you can get the full high
quality MP3 and uh you may notice that
the video version has some sound effects
that the MP3 version does not but it is
I believe on Spotify iTunes it should be
on iTunes I think you can buy on iTunes
I'm not sure but it's like everywhere
and we uh we've got uh someone here who
may be our new composer and which means
likely going to be recording a lot more
music and uh should be a lot of fun I
got a million and one songs that need to
be recorded stoked
whoa what's this Seth Essington says Ian
is making me extremely angry I'm about
to punch my monitor don't do it don't do
it too expensive I'm very passionate
about data transfer Wyatt kaldenberg
says Ian if a farmer grows corn and
everyone steals his corn the farmer will
stop growing corn yeah it's called theft
so what are people consuming when
someone makes music
what are people consuming when a farmer
grows corn
you said they're eating his corn they're
consuming they're consuming they're
destroying what eating the corn what is
a person consuming when someone plays a
song nothing they're not consuming
anything no they're just listening that
that's consumption no it's a vibration
in your ear there's no consumption going
on so consumption is just so you're
you're playing semantics consumption
involves destruction of the product not
no like you're playing cement well okay
give me an idea of something that you
consume that isn't destroyed the beef
the beef a movie right now you don't
consume a movie come on consumers you're
misusing the word consume so what do you
call it like so we say absorbers
sure like AMC refers to the customers
understanders
listeners listeners like
a song and eating a piece of food is
extremely different
yanet Santana says can Ian move to Cuba
I don't think I could legally right Adam
Griffin says intellectual property in
code is also intellectual property I
know it's straight communist for the
state to steal someone's work to
distribute it to the masses
yeah I would never encourage the state
to steal someone's product and
distribute it Smokey says Ian is a
straight up socialist look copyright law
was made by Queen Elizabeth to prevent
people from making copies of the Bible
she wanted control of the information
X Runner says Ian loves blockchain but
hates nft
are you not an nft guy I love nfts oh
okay I was about to say but you can't
copy it full of nonsense non-fungible
all right let's see we'll just do uh
we'll get a couple more in here because
we're getting the bun Thomas
conservatives have sensor proof is great
but what about when you want to be
tracked having an alibi for your
location can sometimes be useful if cops
come and knocking well I'll respond to
that right away just saying just get a
receipt for your donut there you go oh
yeah yeah I use my credit card you know
even if I don't need something just
every once in a while just so that way
you can get a little paper trail of
yourself yeah I like that yeah yeah but
uh but you know you have the option if
you uh if you want to turn that man some
tracking like if you know if you want to
use GPS you have the option to turn that
on yeah exactly you know and then if
there's even uh uh if you want an option
to download an app although we Silo it
and all that you you know we're not
gonna ban you from using Facebook
um you're welcome to although I
discourage it and you'll get a warning
uh uh when you download it and we Silo
it so it is more secure than using
another phone but you know what you do
if you're scrolling on Facebook
um Facebook will see that if using that
app but they won't see or be able to do
anything on the rest of your phone like
you know listen or anything good good
all right let's see
um Hank Trey says I need a shout out for
my shout out my cat he passed away a
week ago and I miss him dearly rip Louie
Louie sad sad to hear it buddy sorry rip
Louie I had a cat I I that was my
favorite pet I have I love dogs love
them but I had a cat and she was she was
like a dog and she was so sweet
Dana and S as Ian if nobody pays for art
the artist will be forced to make a
living by other means and won't be able
to make as much art
well
if you're making art for anything other
than the love of art then you're doing
it wrong
so artists shouldn't be allowed to have
like food in the shelter what do you
mean allowed of course they're allowed
so if there's an artist and they're like
I would like to paint a picture but
deserve it if that's what you mean you
don't deserve things in life you have to
earn them so if someone doesn't start to
make money yeah art is not a profit
thing it's it's art is a it's the
ability to do more like we live you know
it's our ability to make more art right
if someone wants more canvases and buy
more painting material and be able to
have you know so rather than it I mean I
think the goal is always to have art be
a full-time job if you're really into
that not a full-time job but something
that you can do full-time if you can
control the flow or the output of the
flow of your data then you can profit
off of it but once you lose control of
that flow you live in a dark world it's
real it's called reality welcome in my
world people just come to agreements on
how to make sure someone who produces
art can live a beautiful life but in
your version of reality just because the
possibility exists artists should have
to work other jobs and do art on the
side
my middle name's art dude I think that
uh G Prime 85 over here with these
beautiful pictures of Joe Biden eating
children should be allowed to be
compensated and you know what I paid him
for the art yeah but now a million
people are watching this show and seeing
that art for free and he's not making
money but it's making him more famous
and it's making people want to buy them
more yeah so some people are the one
percent of artists and they can make
tons of money off of people displaying
there because it's so good but what
about somebody who just draws like you
know a landscape and that one's you
can't see that one it's not even on the
camera should that person just be like
well it's for the love I'm gonna work 40
hours to make this but I should not get
paid
well you jump up making art it's a fun
job
um you know they used to have patrons
like Leonardo da Vinci or these people
they would Michelangelo they would have
to find someone to fund them to make
their art but I think an artist
shouldn't have to have a sugar daddy or
anything to be able to produce things
but this whole should and shouldn't
thing and what people deserve is like I
don't like that conversation you earn
what you're worth you know like reality
people shouldn't steal corn
the whole [ __ ] I don't like this whole
shouldn't people can steal corn you can
walk right up to a farm and just take it
all well no joke because the farm is so
massive like there's one Farm not too
far from It's A Hundred Acre apple
orchard anybody can walk in and just
take the apples yeah well if you have a
warlord hoarding everyone's corn and
they have to go steal it from the
warlord to survive that has nothing to
do with the local Farm just said people
shouldn't steal corn they should not
what if there's a warlord that has taken
all the corn and now people have to
steal it from them to survive and you
are so desperate for this argument
and people can just walk up and take it
and you said that we shouldn't talk
about should or shouldn't and now people
shouldn't take his corn
people should pay for it people should
pay for the art there you go just
because we found out a way to to
duplicate things online doesn't mean
people should not have to pay for it
hey man I want to code a solution this
is the whole point I think no I think
they did I think streaming services have
solved the problem but you make like
.001 Cent every time someone listens to
it it's not not really a solution the
Spotify Wix makes way more money on
those artists I think it is better than
free I guess yeah yeah you could you're
adapting to an interesting I would like
to see the the user dictate the sale
amount like I would like to see people
be like Spotify you're gonna pay me if
you wanna but I don't know they do want
to get their art seen and heard too so
it's I think that then we're in
agreement then because I think the
artist should be getting paid what they
deserve for their art but what what is
what is that like if you make a 100
million copies for free then what are
those copies really worth 100 millionth
of what the original was worth
I mean if they're free they're they're
free yeah like now you can proliferate
data back in the day you could make play
a song and that was it you had to pay
money to go listen to that now you can
make 100 trillion copies of it at the
cost of next to nothing so I are the
value of those copies also 100
trillionth of the here's the probably
when people would buy an MP3
you would get a dollar for the MP3 and
their right to listen to that song
whenever they wanted now when I listen
to a song on on say Spotify or Pandora
each lesson has a value to it so it's
instead of just one transaction it's a
prolonged transaction the more people
listen to your music the more money you
make that's solving for that problem
because now I don't got to worry about
buying I can literally pull up Spotify
because I have a subscription and just
pick up whatever song I want and then I
can listen to it don't got to worry
about it and it's easier than than
finding some torrent website to download
an album I remember back in the day with
like Kaza and LimeWire you'd see like
you know I'd be like oh Bad Religion and
then you'd click it and it would be
Metallica or something like that this is
dumb or you know it was my favorite
people who would name files after their
own like they'd upload their own band
hoping that like calling it Metallica
would get me to listen to their band
that's hilarious anyway my friends it's
been it's been a blast of Friday night
thanks so much for hanging out and for
all the super chats and the like smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends Friday
is a chill day uh so make sure you go to
timcast.com become a member members only
segments go up Monday through Thursday
but we're gonna be adding more and more
shows so so hang tight because once we
get these next two three shows the D and
D show is gonna be happening we're
having those people we're having some
DND people come out not this weekend but
the next weekend and then we're gonna
have a show which is like d d Adventures
but based on real world political events
to see how people react to certain
situations it'll be a whole lot of fun
it'll be fun to get a socialist and like
an end cap and then be like there's a
climate crisis in the dwarf City or
whatever and like see how they respond
and like I choose to do this it'll be
fun it'll be hilarious it'll be like
hanging out with your friends and having
a good time so uh you can also follow us
at timcast IRL on Facebook and Instagram
at timcast underscore IRL on Tick Tock
and you can follow me personally at
timcast do you want to uh shout out your
social media or anything else Eric yeah
uh if you want to follow me for updates
it's just at Eric finman
e-r-i-k-f-i-n-m-a-n if you want to check
out the freedom phone it's just
freedomphone.com
people keep saying Ian is stealing our
car
dude Eric thank you so much for coming
in thanks for building this too yeah
thank you and and feel free I want
people to check it out tear it apart and
see how good it is because that's that's
the plan and thank you so much for just
having me on Ian and Tim oh thank
everybody you guys follow me Ian
crossland.net I love corn
it's really funny you're stealing it the
the super chats are people saying Ian's
wrong that's what people are paying and
then in the chat which is free
everyone's saying Ian's right oh
interesting reality is changing we have
to adopt we have to adapt I guess the
one percent coming out in the comments
yeah well I am very glad to have Eric
this is a really fun conversation I
don't really enjoy all the arguing but
I'm glad it happens and I'm glad that we
have free speech to do it and you guys
can follow me at Sour Patch Lids on
Twitter as I attempt to gain more
followers than Sour Patch Kids don't
follow them follow me head over to
youtube.com cast Castle we're going to
have an episode of the Vlog up tomorrow
at nine the Vlog crew is expanding and
we're hoping to soon be moving into
daily Vlogs we'll see if we can get
there we'll make it work I mean we're a
busy company but the more people who are
here the more the crazier things get and
then you'll also see some of the behind
the scenes stuff when like the guests
arrive and it'll it'll be fun and silly
so uh again it's youtube.comcast castle
at 9am tomorrow morning thanks for
hanging out and Ian was wrong we'll see
you all next time us